um
why don't you cut to the set show people
what we're working with here
we've got roasts from all of your
favorites
we've got quite a show planned that
looks great let me say that again
the pits of hell is where i'll be today
i'm 36 man that is old as [ __ ]
please stand up
man so after the break we're gonna move
over to the set
and everybody is gonna take turns we've
got submissions from everybody
from logic to
uh vsauce donkey steve oh
idubbbz phillyd all of your favorites
many
many more i am i'm wow it's funny
last night we felt like nobody was
coming through and i was like that's the
biggest roast of all
[Laughter]
nice but we actually got a lot of people
coming through which i'm very touched by
it's very nice gesture of them it was
very last minute too so people who
couldn't get it in
we love you no hey but we will be
calling each and every one of you by
name
yep and doxing you and your address and
phone number
today's episode is sponsored by shady
rays and liquid iv
what a week it's been eh oh yeah from
the crowder
to my mom to now the roast it's been a
big
big beautiful week the h3 podcast well
what a [ __ ] night i have to say
that i've been like
enjoying that crowder moment for the
whole week
yeah you know i know i mean i knew it
was great but i didn't realize it was
going to be such a moment because i feel
like the internet's been buzzing
about this crowd rv sam cedar thing
and uh i just love it because there's
been such a meltdown
um i'm gonna talk about that but before
we get oh by the way i just want to say
before we get into it really fast
ela i'm not gonna pretend like there's
not a new teddy fresh release today that
you've been working your ass off on
so teddyfresh.com you want to talk about
anything specifically
um hey work it girl work it
work it work it stand up ela
stand
[Applause]
i'm wearing a size up yeah you know this
uh camp shirt
sold out in like 10 minutes that's crazy
that's such an honor because
i love this shirt and we worked so hard
on it it started looking beautiful
completely different
like so different and then we were just
like
let's just keep going with it we're just
having fun and then uh works
and change work it work it well anyway
you can't buy it because it's sold out
thank you to everyone who continuously
um support what we do it's just amazing
yeah well you're making dope [ __ ] so
what what choice do they have
um but anyway check it out
teddyfresh.com there's all kinds of
great stuff there well i've seen a lot
of sold out
amazing all right that's that
okay so um actually you know we got a
message from donald trump even
the presidents are well ex-president
i'll say he's still president i mean
a lot of people still think he's
president so
who am i they're still counting votes in
like arizona so you know you never know
they are like that yeah they are okay
dan i'm having an issue with my clique
it like doesn't click
all right donna what the [ __ ]
the bros hasn't started my bad i'm
i'm clicking the laptop and nothing's
happening bro i wonder if your mom
messes up look click click
she was another addiction are you
[ __ ] with me no i swear to god i'm
not
i wonder if your mom [ __ ] it up are
you [ __ ] with me no i am not [ __ ]
i'm clicking the video that well that
was what kept happening in my mom i
don't know if you watched okay
yeah i'm halfway through that we did the
episode with my mom it was so funny
the craziest part about that episode was
that i did a sudoku puzzle
yeah i didn't get to by the way i saw
people like oh it only took me three
minutes
good for you dude i don't play sudoku
it's like dude give me a break
oh it took me three minutes fine i
actually thought you did really well
we literally had to teach him how to
play from the ground up like
20 minutes before the show so the fact
that he solved it i did a long time ago
but i didn't remember like because
there's all these little strategies
yeah you don't like uh stuff like that
right like when there's a
the stuff with words in the newspaper
like crossword crossword
i'm not it's not that i hate crossovers
just who [ __ ] plays crosstalk i've
never seen you
i've never seen you play crossword who
are you i used to do it in israel a lot
but
in america yeah in english
i feel like that should happen that's
just good for your brain though like
if i feel like if you play that when you
get old your brain will be good
nice and juicy brain i tried one time in
english and i was like oh [ __ ] i don't
even know one thing
maybe i should start for my brain
deteriorates
i'm getting 36 already all right here's
donald trump's message for us
ethan it's me president trump but if
you're looking for a new
co-host for frenemies no one is more of
a friend of me
than me i practically invented the
phrase
for enemies uh so i'm the guy i'm the
guy
believe me believe me it'll be
absolutely huge to have me
as your co-host duran should go through
the roof through the roof
trump is down bad man he's trying to
co-host a podcast
legend yeah you don't know
what do you guys think trump for
frenemies i'm not sure hm
i'll have to think about it oh this is
really exciting
okay there's no such thing as a
coincidence one of the
you know most uh prolif i hate to say it
but prolific
uh memes that's come out and he the guy
put out a new video that is
phenomenal um there's no such thing as a
coincidence here
ela have you seen this oh yeah oh
man everybody well here you maybe you
guys haven't seen it yet
there is no such thing as a coincidence
the fact that you're watching this
yes your thoughts create your reality
but you already knew that yet you still
live a life that you dread
when you visualize your dream life you
unconsciously believe
that it is unrealistic here's the hack
i've created okay it doesn't matter what
he says now
the question is is this real i feel like
it is
dude but why wouldn't he cut in this
world people go
there's a whole debate about is this guy
a genius or was this just
like what incredible moment caught on
camera
i feel like he's not a comedic genius he
just like
there's no way he is a comedic genius
there's no such chance that he's a
comedic genius and watch this again
but is this plant so perfect do you see
her coming up the fact that you're
watching this video
means you're energetically aligned with
me and this message
your thoughts create your reality but
you already knew that
i didn't know that you still live a life
that you dreamed
and you know that's the appropriate
response if a guy like that
snaps over to you was that just her
reaction to his look
yeah oh my god i think she didn't expect
his
face there's
a monster in the woods or something talk
about energies being aligned and stuff
she thought she wants to get zapped up
to the ufo
what do you guys think real or planned i
i want to believe it's real because it's
so [ __ ] funny we uh
maybe actually just whipped up a straw
poll i am dropping it into the chat
right now
audience what do you think is it real
here's the thing this guy has not
shown any inkling that he is commit
comedically inclined
yeah that's the thing he's so
self-serious that it this scene and this
is
so fun for him yeah and also it's not
even like
it's like a great joke i don't think he
would come up with such a joke
there is no such thing as a coincidence
the fact that you guys are watching this
podcast right now
right now means that we are
energetically aligned and that um
there's no we're all gonna be having a
fantastic weekend
there's no such thing as the coincidence
so the early votes are in uh the yeses
are having it by quite a bit
uh yes it's real i'm sorry the
the yes is the video real is the
question and it's uh 70
yes to 30 no 30 is a significant amount
of doubters
that's a lot of doubters no but that out
of all the polls we've done 70
is is a dominant win yeah but like
that means you filmed it and then left
it in
i went for what the leaving it in is
part of like his uh
energy lifestyle of like no coincidence
right this was meant to happen
you know um he must have shown it to his
friends
and then they've been like you have to
post that the fact that you're watching
this video
means you're energetically aligned with
me and this message
your thoughts create your reality but
you already knew that
yet you still live a life that you dread
dude how can you react like that
there's no such thing as a coincidence
but then he doesn't even smile i mean
how can he not miss a beat
it's like how can he not miss a beat and
then continue like nothing
no apologies no laughter
what the [ __ ] it's so out of pocket for
his normal content
i agree
either way it's amazing i i want to
believe it's real yeah well the uh
the percentages are staying pretty
steady as the votes continue to come in
so it looks like the
the reals have it let's see what he has
to say though i'm curious what's his
message today
bro when you visualize your dream life
you unconsciously believe that it is
unrealistic
here's a hack i've created a dream life
meditation
that uses questions and binaural beats
when presented with the question
your mind must accept it and your
subconscious mind
will absorb it what when listening to
binaural beats
it puts your mind into theta frequency
data allowing you access
to your subconscious mind link in the
bio oh he's just trying to sell some
product
it's an ad it's an ad that's us
because he's creating a viral moment
let's get a look at this job
how serious is she jogging right now
well you already knew this is a real
jogger
you still live a life that you dress
excuse me
it's too funny for him i don't think he
could think of something yeah how could
you think
of that sponsor think of it and ask him
to do something goofy
no sponsors don't ever do that yes he
doesn't
sponsors don't usually sponsors have
only bad ideas yeah
only bad ideas exclusively the chat is
spamming to turn the sign on
i will i will get on that looks like
ourselves we're having problems with the
science yeah
what's going on it was on what happened
it was on
i know oh abe you have a gift for me you
want to do that
right now oh it is it is a coincidence
the fact is that's the coincidence
what do we got here shredder [ __ ] him up
don't step to me without asking
permission from shredder all right i
have a gift from uh a b
here this is from maybe that's what it
says it's actually from all of us
okay no it's not all right ab
let's see what you got here
we got a shirt
oh sound came on it's a shirt with
something in it
there's something in the shirt hmm oh
wait okay
this is from ab huh
it's hagrid with the sorting hat
covering his privates
oh my god are you kidding me did you not
know that
it's a sexy hey weren't we talking about
this i thought we saw that image but i
didn't
i i didn't know about this gift i didn't
know that he got it
is that too graphic maybe maybe
i mean it's just a drawing
that of course goes with the um the
hagrid fan fiction
we did recently yes you did so good i
want to get you the canvas we saw but
it wouldn't come in time so i made you
that custom shirt so someone correct
yeah i want to buy that
thank you abe that was very thoughtful
i'm gonna be wearing that you're welcome
enjoy it i'll be wearing that a lot
i want that original art i want to
commission that and put it up at the
entrance of our house hila first thing
you see
[Music]
don't know about that all right so
before we get to the roast obviously i
gotta talk about the crowder thing
wait real quick yeah as a tease for the
roast
we have a little message from somebody
that normally we check in with on friday
but it's not friday it's thursday it's
thursday baby
but we didn't want to go in after dark
without a little message from gabe so uh
send it in all right
ian when you're ready go ahead let's uh
take it away
yeah i don't know if you can handle your
babies and fried chicken once they've
been [ __ ]
right now you're in camp but i think
you're not ready [ __ ]
what is he saying yeah anyways
happy birthday ethan thank you baby
what was what did he say he was saying
you're not ready for more kids
he roasted the
yes he did i love gabe is evolving and
the
but the woos are subtle but like
powerful
yeah you come out with a strong [ __ ]
babies and then a woo
like a gentle morning dove that was
brutal i don't know how to recover from
that one he's right though i'm not ready
all facts from gabe that's right
all right let's just talk about crowder
real fast and we'll get to the roast
because there's oh you know what else i
want to talk about before we get to the
roast free britney oh yeah free brittany
or i'm [ __ ] writing
i'm swear to god dude this is this i i'm
so disgusted by this free britney [ __ ]
i'm about to
burn it all down
i'm i'm this guy is fully redeemed man
yeah
did the light go off again oh no it's on
[Music]
i do it i'm team him he was ahead of the
game bro that guy's like a prophet
we are energetically aligned with him
all right let's talk about crowder
crowder released a video trying to for
those of you guys who didn't see
crowder is this com is the work he's a
conservative commentator
an apparent assault he apparently he
says he's a comedian but i haven't seen
any evidence of that
he always says he's a comedian but like
worthy what a [ __ ] nightmare i don't
get it
anyway he we we completely owned him
he's been dodging this uh
other political commentator called um
sam
cedar who's a very intelligent skilled
uh political analyst and debater and
crowder because he's full of [ __ ] and he
knows that his
all of his beliefs are just a total
grift
that and it all falls apart immediately
when when uh faced with the real
opponent
he's been dodging him we got him good he
wanted to debate me
and we surprised him with sam cedar uh
you guys probably all seen the video but
he titled his video the greatest self
own h3h3 wrecks himself and brags about
it
i thought ethan was a stand-up guy yeah
i don't know who told him that
wrong i was like who told you that bro
i thought we were best friends well he
it's it's
okay so here we put together a little um
edit to show the all of the irony's
inconsistency and lies of stephen
um first you guys remember when this
whole
this whole rift started he was going
ethan
who is his name ethan i don't know who
he is ethan
is it ethan but i don't have to think
about it dude
but then suddenly when i get in front of
him he's like oh h3
these one of the og's i love his content
so here
i used to love his content which is what
all the conservatives say to burn me
apparently
it's like yeah well i'm glad you don't
anymore
that's kind of the point i don't want
you watching my [ __ ] here's something
that i really wanted to touch on oh boy
this guy
uh i think his name what's his what's
his name there uh uh token allen is it
is his real name
ethan ethan ethan ethan yeah is it the
agency yeah
it's ethan ethan what is it ethan ethan
alkin i've never seen someone pretend so
hard not to know someone it's such a
regular name like
yeah you said it right ethan doesn't
have to think about it dude
ethan get there
ethan cline your mics on there i
remember him back in the day and i used
to
okay so now here he is talking about me
and and
where i self-owned back in the day and i
used to say he remembered
his content but i remember i supported
him or he said hey youtube should
actually find a way to monetize my
content i don't do we don't do debates
based on
why i just don't want to have a debate
based on a lie
so that was his defense is that you want
to have a debate based on the lie
i don't know what that means oh that he
wasn't because
he was lied about sam cedar being here
because he wanted to have a debate on
with somebody that
is not a debater is not familiar with
all the politics
so that he can look like a cool epic
dude yeah
but you know what here this was actually
great this guy uh
senk is that how you say his name a [ __ ]
oh jank
from the young turks he's like hassan's
uncle yeah hassan's uncle actually
interestingly
um was like this guy's so full of [ __ ]
he
ambushed me at south by southwest so for
him to be like oh i don't want to debate
based on this
is like once again one of the many
hypocrisies
and cowardice of stephen crowder i'll
play it here
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen right i think he's
mostly just funny because
or i think he's mostly just angry
because what we did was actually funny
you know yeah
which this is way more disrespectful
than what we did yeah he's crashing his
panel
apparently he bought a super expensive
ticket crash the panel and then wouldn't
leave
by the way until he was forcibly removed
by security
so [ __ ] stupid bro but honestly his
biggest crime and is just not even being
funny right like
gotta say the guy is not funny for
someone
how does he consider himself a comedian
with the straight faces beyonce
i'm gonna go up there and say what he
says that's so annoying
[Music]
he's such a coward [ __ ] that he's going
to cry about being ambushed he's
done the same thing this is get the [ __ ]
over [ __ ] nike
so he says now sam said he wouldn't let
him speak
which is odd because crowder was just
panicking and shouting over
everybody the whole time and you could
see sam sitting patiently respectfully
because sam really actually wanted to
have a conversation as we all did want
to see that
and crowder is just panicking and
flailing
the whole time as you'll see here ever
let
[Music]
can i answer your question can i answer
your question can i answer your question
you want me to answer your question my
audience would say sam who for me
the whole by the way his whole argument
was like nobody knows who you are
then why is this turned into such a big
story yeah yeah
clearly everybody knows who he is and
knows about this thing of you not
wanting to debate him
because it be turned into this huge
story so like
basically i'm sorry about a million
subscribers that's
well that's not little of course not
that's a massive channel
yeah especially for like political
topics right it's niche
yeah and he's very much in the details
where crowder is just doing like
performative like click bait
outrage stuff where sam's actually has
like hour-long
interviews about a single issue it's
very dry
and detailed yeah i had no idea this was
going to happen
such panic but it's it's just funny
because basically his two arguments was
one
nobody knows who you are which he
immediately contradicted himself by
admitting that he was following his show
to watch if he went live the previous
week so we actually had to dupe him
pre-record fake going live to get him to
go
on with us this time so and also by the
evidence that the entire internet
exploded talking about this is further
proof
that everybody knows who he is
but again you know the ultimate slam
dunk to that is like if you
don't want to if you don't want to have
debates with people who
are uh you who people don't know who
they are then why do you set up at
college campuses
right so it's [ __ ] stupid probably
it's good the guy it doesn't make you
it's bizarre too
maybe i didn't watch the entirety of his
version of the events or whatever but
maybe somebody who did did he
try and frame it as if ethan was the one
that challenged him to a debate
because i'm seeing that from his
supporters all over the place i'm like
are they unaware of that really steven
is the one who started this
he issued the challenge oh yeah so in
his response video
he said it about four times he said that
ethan was the one that
and you know reached out to me he says
real quick oh i invited him first on the
show and then like throughout the show
like four different four different
occasions he laid
honestly i don't really even care it's
like you just got owned bro yeah i got
pumped yeah who cares
he goes weird he wrote me this long
email about um
his dad actually wrote this email he
keeps tap dancing around the fact that
his dad is his booker and his handler
and everything
his dad wrote us an email being like
just a one-on-one debate
no razzes no funny business
and i didn't even respond i was like
dude just [ __ ] set up the debate
douche there will be razzes
i'm gonna i'm gonna razz you bro i
didn't agree to anything by the way i
didn't say okay no funny business right
he said
when i was communicating with his dad as
well he said something like uh
you know no no goofs uh let's just play
this straight or whatever
i didn't even agree to that yeah i
didn't i just said i said all yours just
send me the zoom link
not that it matters even it's like if
you're such a if you're such a genius
that predicted this you probably should
have been better prepared for it yeah
right
so it's like everything he's tried to
say to excuse this
is just absolutely contradicted by what
happened
it's awesome a man makes an agreement
but he definitely he challenged
my whole point of satirizing this was
because he
challenged me to a debate yeah and it's
like wow and i was like
exactly right exactly
so i was like okay let's have a debate
we saw the opportunity
and we took it and you're a sucker
simple as that dude and i don't know who
told you i was a good guy you spent like
three episodes trashing me so i don't
know
i'm confused by what made you think that
and a man is good to his word
yeah this really comes down to an
agreement good to your word and i know
you always have two
i didn't ever agree to [ __ ] you should
see the conversation
i literally didn't agree to anything you
said he showed the
dms yeah yeah yeah so everybody can see
you i didn't agree with that he just
he's like okay here blah blah blah i was
like just send the link douchebag
i didn't agree to anything but at the
same time in his response video he's
talking about
switching up the subject on you in this
part we're watching right now he's
saying he want to switch and talk about
big tech
great point oh yeah because he was like
let's talk about
covet and trusting authorities and stuff
i obviously didn't give a [ __ ] what we
were gonna debate because the whole time
i was
gonna dunk on him
but here he is saying he was going to he
was going to try to switch the topic
science will claim your side wins but
really there's only one side that's
based on a lie and i just
i wish it didn't happen because i really
wanted to talk to him about his his
relationship with susan wojcicki and uh
oh what so he was going to try to find
me about my relationship with susan
waginski
or a relationship that i took a photo
with her once you know what that is
right
but is that the part of the oh you think
the defense jewish the jewish
but that's actually a good point as well
no i was that's that's
him uh having a conversation with uh
with our buddy jeremy
jeremy yeah oh
where else would that come from come on
100 i believe
jeremy is the source of all the quarters
yeah yes because
quartering is uh a huge fan of stephen
crowd right now
and has been a guest on his show several
times so just beat in my basement
everyone's
zach come on come on
whenever we did the interview whenever
we got crowded that jeremy's pissing
everywhere
like that i feel all over his house all
over the dog the neighborhood
everywhere well i would assume there's
probably some evidence of that
there will be my wife just went out for
pizza without me
my wife and i pizza without me to
everyone that follows that
whole um conspiracy of you having a
relationship with susan there is some
like
advanced racism to that right yeah
because all i did was say
she came to our podcast studio one time
i talked to her
about my by the way i tried to [ __ ]
benefit all these dip [ __ ]
i know i talked to her monetizing mature
content
yeah as i i said to her why is it that
when i talk about something racy or i
have content made for adults
that i can't get ads when if you go
watch south park or something on comedy
central these are the highest
advertised shows i was like it literally
doesn't make sense and she's deep
undercover
and so so now in their minds it's turned
into this uh
jewish conspiracy where i'm best friends
with
it was like one meeting okay bye um
she she meets a lot of creators yeah she
met like 10 creators on that trip to l.a
and so anyway this is him all having
ulterior motive so once again just being
a total hypocrite
you know i just beat him to the punch
so so tell me about your relationship
with just susan wojcinski she's jewish
right by the way and uh you are as well
you guys are the same synagogue or yeah
yeah
i'm interesting a flip in the support of
big tech
because also keep in mind too i had to
navigate some murky waters here
because the goal was to remove me from
medical misinformation any conversations
about covet ethan has talked about that
in the past said your co-host sounds
like a drunk when his co-host sounds
like helen keller
okay hold on i didn't say you sound like
a drunk i said you are a drunk
every time i see this guy he's sitting
there with a mug
and his face is bloodshot and i'm like
this guy is drunk all the time
and so this was very early in the
morning so you probably hadn't had your
first sip of alcohol yet
apparently they said he is a recovering
alcoholic so i guess the the
oh the the i hit the it right on the
head there
touch the nerve yeah and by the way i
said he was a little leprechaun
i wasn't trying to make fun of his
stature that he he actually does
his face is very like lucky charms-ish
but i was making fun because he came
dressed as like peter pan as an
episode before and i was just making fun
of their little dress up i think that
was actually the other host or the other
uh
well regardless i i was just yeah i was
recalling the costumes yeah
but the the he is very lucky charms
and stature and face so
it works that in the past said your
co-host sounds like a drunk when his
co-host sounds like helen keller
learning water
he's making fun of you because you have
an accent
also they don't like women he said
didn't one of them say stop being a
woman
to me yeah he said he's never met such a
woman yeah
really something like that yeah he did
pretty gay
[Laughter]
you've never met such a woman
i make the gay jokes because they're
such such
raging homophobes and transphobes of
course and i got news for you
that means you get yeah
who what kind of in this year what kind
of insult is that to say i've never
met such a woman like dude how [ __ ]
traumatized were you by your mother i
mean what is that yeah
so how do what do you think about the
comparison to helen keller
i don't know i mean this this guy
especially is like
so unfunny yeah i couldn't care less
what he says
i think he's just there to make steven
look funny by comparison
maybe you know so [ __ ] stupid bro
really the issue is um is ethan's wife
because it's your job to try and beat
the cowardice out of your husband
right that's the thing when you have a
son you have to make sure that they
understand what integrity is i mean
stephen that's rich coming from the guy
who lied about his [ __ ]
pregnant wife that's great coming from
the guy who still has his dad running
his business
get him who's getting roasted at me or
steven yeah
yeah well what a [ __ ] nightmare
yeah oh by the way i said the spartan
joke again i said do you know spartans
have
man love with children is because he's
got the spartan armored system on his
desk but once again he's such a
homophobe
that i find it deeply ironic
that this these people love
gay sex the spartans they're huge in the
gay sex
ethan i have to i have to compliment you
on on that joke
uh because that was such a perfect
lead-in
yeah i mean it just totally was just
like well i feel like
i just want to make it clear because i
feel like a lot of people weren't
sure what i was doing there they're like
what it's just a weird comment maybe but
it's a reference to the spartan on the
desk it was it was just
jeff kim did a good job of just putting
him off balance oh yeah
yeah totally [ __ ] this [ __ ] up so many
things in that video just worked
perfectly i mean i remember you guys
talking about vape nation once how just
everything just lined up perfectly
that's
like right when he hung up he you're
like cold feet again and then he hung up
right again
after that it was beautiful i just wish
you would have actually debated and not
been such a coward
genuinely i i that was the preferable
outcome here i had never expected him to
debate i knew he would just
uh just leave the chat yeah i mean the
the irony is saying
i knew you'd do anything to avoid
debating and that's exactly what he did
yeah you know i actually my my bet was
that it was just going to be an instant
hang up i was i was actually surprised
he stuck around as long as he did
i'm glad he did me too yeah i am i
thought he would uh i thought he would
hang up i thought it would have been
like [ __ ] you i'm gone i thought ethan
was a stand-up guy although he i dude
he would have yeah no i again i love
that line because i never did nobody i
know ever told him that
for me a man makes an agreement and a
man is good to his words my mind
is very different well i'm not a man i'm
the most woman apparently
apparently men [ __ ] men keep their word
and women lie
you are the most woman person i've ever
met
i am delivered from a debate i changed
my mind the whole goal to change my mind
for example is an anti-debate
he looks like an edging toddler
what that's what i'm saying this guy's
so unfunny but look at him
also all toddlers are aging just right
good point ap
thank you and you look wait hold on
watching toddlers
they come up with the most random
unfunny jokes that i've ever heard
yeah i don't know if this is like
conservative humor well the thing is he
calls it
he's not computing in my brain but
they're like so unfunny in these guys
a lot of the funny things we've heard
hassan said it's like high level racism
yeah he has like a phd in racism like
what he was trying to say about samus
he said sam is the velveteen rabbit and
everyone was like in the lab
trying to figure out what that meant i
said it twice i was like i was googling
in real time i'm like what is velveteen
rabbit is this old story book like
i think i do i do think it was uh uh
like
bdi uh i do think it was an anti-semitic
trope i really do
yeah i saw a writer post they said it's
based on some old uh
whatever about saying that holders don't
have a soul because there's like oh
me said and do you have a soul you have
a soul yeah let me see your eyes
yeah yeah all toddlers are aging that's
a really good point maybe
because that that's the normal state of
being a toddler
what am i benjamin button what am i
aging backwards i mean what the [ __ ]
unless you're like crowder where you
don't grow up you just yeah
boy forever yep daddy daddy i had a hard
day at work
he's dunking his donuts and i know that
was too easy but you're a fat piece of
[ __ ]
okay the problem that i have with this
joke is that
he says the only thing that's just too
funny he says
okay the only thing he's dunking is
donuts i'm like did you get that from
jokes.com i mean that could be
that could be literally used on anybody
in any situation
yeah that guy literally can't say one
relevant joke
the only thing he's dunking is donuts
dude last time i checked you were a fat
[ __ ] little porky pig dude you look
like a porky pig bro
just put a some apple in your mouth and
cook you up for [ __ ]
spit roast baby i'm gonna spit roast you
boy you look he looks magically
delicious
[Laughter]
he's like
[Laughter]
dude he's the um he's the lucky charms
uh he's the lucky charms uh
oh he's the lucky charm leprechaun if it
was all mushrooms
[ __ ] i can't eat it right i have a good
joke
he's the lucky charm leprechaun if it
was all
marshmallows oh this is a mushroom right
yeah i know i said mushroom yeah it
would have been better the first time i
tried my prank don't work so good i
tried to dig but nothing happened
but can you imagine if i went to
jokes.com and prepped the only thing
he's dunking
is donuts
i use that joke every day
so i don't know if i'd want to watch his
show or rather watch
two hours of the san francisco gay
chorus
san francisco gay chorus these guys
literally can't even not go
homophobic i said the gay chorus did
y'all catch that
i would rather watch the gay chorus so
who is gay why do gay people make you so
uncomfortable stephen you need to ask
yourself that
right be straighter i'd rather pay for
front row nickelback seats
oh zach's [ __ ] mad it would be more
straight
uh
yeah implying nickelback is gay is that
apparently nipple-bound
nickelback is the manliest [ __ ] stephen
all right oh boy here we go
why do you think steven is so but can
you believe that this is how he speaks
like his
uh analogy to what's not good is how gay
it is
yeah or female energy it is that i mean
this is like when i was in middle school
yeah and then you grow up it's hard to
believe that it's real
but he obviously being gayness or
homosexuality makes him so uncomfortable
that it makes me wonder
yeah he does make me want he goes i'd
rather i don't know what's gayer
watching ethan or
gay seats
i'm not gonna say it but you know what
i'm thinking a ding-dong
far from the first to speculate far from
the first
um we are at uh 38 minutes we should
really do our ads
oh okay we have an ad but actually
interestingly enough
um we've been talking about stephen's
dad
uh he was super pissed because we didn't
stick to our word or
he's like stephen's dad emailed me he's
like you are such a woman you are
he's like he's like you're not invited
to our house anymore you can't play with
my son
my son thought timeout because of you
my son's watching the get what did he
say about the the gay
the san francisco gay chorus um
is that a thing i mean yeah yeah
why does he know about that why does he
have that in his backpack
um dude the guy is flaming
steven is
san francisco gay course that's just a
report that stephen keeps in his back
pocket
so anyway his dad wanted to call in and
uh and scold us
here we go the san francisco gay men's
chorus
is the first openly gay course one of
the world's largest male courses in the
group often
credited with creating the lgbtq
quarrel movement so stephen
stephen is fantasizing about getting
front row seats to that
he is and they're probably very
musically talented so it would be a good
yeah they're very famous um
steven he has a lot of what people have
referred to as
theater kid energy if you um if you knew
the theater kids
in high school at all um it's a certain
type
and with all the dress-up and theatrics
that he seems to
always enjoy doing um you know
it's not really surprising that he's
familiar with the uh
with the gay chorus well i don't want to
out him you know it's not
it's not my place to out we don't know
anything doesn't that make you no that's
what i'm saying it's not my place to
out him sure yeah if he's in the closet
it's not my place to take him out
right or even to point out that he's in
the closet right
or if even if there is a closet i'm sure
he has a closet in his house maybe more
than most
he might spend time in there he might i
mean surely picking out outfits he goes
in the closet
how long's he in the closet and i got
news for you that means you're gay a
long time
all right let's do these ads and then we
can get to the damn roast
we'll call we'll talk to steven's dad
and then we'll get to the roast sounds
good
shady rays high quality shades for less
than expensive brands
i don't understand why sunglasses are so
freaking expensive
well shady rays is out to change the
game they're an independent sunglass
company so they do things their own way
something that's very rare in the
industry that's true i watch this
documentary about what's the name of
that company that like owns every
designer brand some italian company they
own like
louis vuitton right no it's like a more
generic name no they they own like they
like
they it's like they make all the
sunglasses forever that's why they're so
expensive it's just a total scheme
that's why shady rays is able to make
premium polarized shades at the fraction
of the price of the big name brands
so you can stop over paying for
sunglasses that you're too afraid to get
dirty
save your dollars gain some peace of
mind with the best most affordable
shades for outdoors
the best part about shady rays they have
craziest
warranty oh lexa lexatica
yeah i once knew how to say that anyway
forget about that we're talking about
shady rays they got the craziest
warranty
if it's lost or broken they replace that
[ __ ]
no questions asked bro that's insane if
you lose or break your shades on day one
they'll send you a brand new pair no
questions asked dropped in a lake ocean
anything they'll replace it
every pair of shades raised is
guaranteed for life so take it on your
next adventure with the team that has
your back
even when uh even with that strong
warranty they still manage to make
quality
that you know will last you forever
starts at just 48 bucks hold uh
that's it you know shady raise also
provides 10 meals to fight hunger in
america with every order placed
and have donated over 15 million meals
to date
they stand behind their product and i've
told our team if anyone has a problem
they will throw profit out the window
and do whatever it takes to make it
right
free returns and exchanges you either
love the shades
or shady rays will pay to ship them back
that's it change the way you wear
sunglasses and give shady rays a free
risk-free shot we think you're going to
love them and if it's not for you can
return them for free anyway
no risk exclusively for our listener
shady's raise is running
the deepest deal of the season with code
h3
you get 50 off two or more pairs at
shadyraise.com that's buy one get one
free folks
you get two pairs for 48 bucks you can
redeem that at
only at shadyrace.com where you can find
all their newest and best
shades code h3 thank you
shady raise i want to show it real fast
because i didn't
just give you guys an idea really cool
glasses woody
i like that woody bro maybe with that
woody [ __ ] bro
[ __ ] remember
[Music]
you didn't have to think about it oh we
should start using that on our sponsors
you don't have to think about it anyway
that's shady rays god bless them we got
one more here
liquid iv we love it dan do you love
liquid iv
what happened yes i do i was muted
liquid iv
it comes in a pack oh damn doing a
demonstration what kind of liquid iv are
you drinking there oh i think this one's
just a vitamin c
hello immune based yeah cellular
transport technology
oh this one is actually uh just the um
oh no it is immune smart yeah this is
the vitamin c one
and it's tangerine flavored so they have
one that's like caffeine too like energy
boost and that's one i like
you don't want to drink coffee you want
to drink a little something to hydrate
you
liquid iv is the way to do it honestly
they've got it's you know for workout
yoga meditation
it helps jump start your day clear your
head give you energy
with one stick of liquid iv and 16
ounces of water you also get two to
three times
faster and more efficient hydration than
water alone
say what yes sir how do you use liquid
iv well dan just
just demonstrated you pour it in
you drink it yeah how's it taste this
one's really good actually it's
tangerine
um yeah i like to drink it if i'm like
in the evening if i need to do some more
work
i i like the energy boost one in the
morning sometimes i don't like drawing
drinking coffee i'll be honest it's too
acidic it just messes my stomach up so
you hit yourself with a liquid iv
and you're getting water you're getting
hydrated it contains five essential
vitamins more vitamin c than an orange
and as much potassium as a banana
it's healthier than sugary sports drinks
there's no artificial flavors or
preservatives and less sugar than an
apple
it's made with clean ingredients it's
non-gmo vegan free of gluten dairy and
soy
you know it's got the special cellular
transport
technology the optimal ratio of glutos
glucose sodium and potassium delivers
water nutrients into the bloodstream
to help hydrate quickly and effectively
once take a liquid iv 16 ounce of water
blah blah blah gives you two to three
bottles of water we said that
liquid iv is on a mission to change the
world the company is donating 4 million
servings in response to covenant 19.
products are being donated to hospitals
first responders food banks veterans
and active military they've already
donated 10 million servings
globally grab your liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco
or you can get 25 percent off when you
go to liquidity.com and use code h3 at
checkout
that's 25 off anything you order when
you get
better hydration today using the promo
code h3
at liquidity.com get 25 off thank you
all right so real quick
i actually have some breaking news go
ahead i just gave you a link in discord
that you should take a look at is it
crowder it it happens to be crowder
related
no way and it's from 12 minutes ago no
what a [ __ ] nightmare
he got banned from tick tock what did he
do i mean
it's pretty easy to guess i don't know
dude
he did his normal thing we know like
tick tock is uh
he is very yeah they don't play away
with anything i saw he just made a tick
tock he
came wrong he was talking about our
thing
about how he doesn't want to debate
under a lie or something and then people
are like oh cool so cool you're on tick
tock he literally already got banned
yeah those damn man with the weight
steven crowder's bigotry has found a
home on tick tock far right internet
personality is now using tick tock to
spread hate the younger audience
sorry what are you saying i was just
gonna say with the way that he
talks and all this like homophobia and
racism i'm not surprised i actually yeah
tick dog don't play games man
yeah by the way his his
tick tock name is mug club i mean it's
so corny bro
anyway may to june it didn't last a
month
wow um i'm surprised you're still on
youtube after that george floyd
reenactment
but hey this is what this is what blows
my mind about him and a lot of these
people
it youtube genuinely one of the most
tolerant platforms i mean
by far but like well facebook is like
you can execute people we don't
yeah that's true i guess facebook but
compared to tick tock twitter instagram
like
most platforms like you can get away
with a lot on youtube yeah you can't
think about it dude yeah i know and then
yeah so do we have his dad on the phone
yeah uh let me uh bring him in right now
stand by all right so this
is stephen crowder's dad his manager and
handler
uh he wanted to call in and yell at us
he wanted to talk to my dad but my dad's
not available
yeah so uh darren darren are you there
hey hey hello hmm hi darren
hello hey hi mr crowder i'm here to give
you a taste of your own element of
surprise medicine pal i'm here to drop
some truth bombs that'll uh
change your mind about us bucko okay mr
uh
big crowder um so cr uh
what do you want to tell me you were
surprised were you upset
with stephen that he uh got got so hard
i mean i know you told us no razzes well
let me tell you something
bud i watch sam cedar every day to make
sure he's live when we are and i'll give
it to him he makes a few points
good points here and there but i told
little stevie this would happen
he should have been more prepared yeah
you were you were very paranoid that sam
cedar was going to be on the call
i mean it seems like you guys are
monitoring his channel very closely
which is a little bit ironic
yeah i mean he uh he forced me to lie
about his wife having a medical
emergency too it was a real uh
embarrassment for the crowder family
right because last week he said
he saw steven end it or he saw sam ended
his show
early and then said that he had a
medical emergency with his wife that's
pretty embarrassing
yeah you want to talk embarrassing go
listen up chief i put him on timeout
after his performance in that debate
oh that was a real embarrassment you put
him on timeout no it doesn't mean he
gets like no
tv for a week he's not allowed to play
with his guns for a week he's not even
allowed to go out and play with peter
pan
oh oh that's too far mr crowder yeah
well i don't know about that i even i
even had to spank him and i told him
this is what happens when you disobey
your father bud
yeah how old is she again he's like what
33 or something like that
hey he's 33 going on 12. what can i say
he's still got it
he still needs uh he needs to go down he
needs some guidance
yeah yeah i'm giving him integrity
integrity with my hand who's
his rear you know you spank him
every day every day he's got to keep him
in line i get that
yeah um wow well
um i mean do you do you even like your
son it doesn't sound like you don't even
like him
uh you know who who cares about him he's
a money machine at this point
oh you're just using him for money yeah
yeah well listen up with your ears sweet
pea because i'm a man of honesty i'm
gonna lay it down
i'm gonna tell you the truth right here
right now just follow the talking points
the koch brothers provide
you know my son isn't the brightest so
we uh try to avoid him going off script
as much as possible
how about that huh that makes sense
that's why they want to avoid the debate
so bad because he kind of has to
improvise a little bit
yeah he flipped the [ __ ] because of it
yeah that makes sense by the way he kept
lying about me saying the booker wasn't
real
uh is the booker he said that he never
tried to book me for the show
but that he's lying about that right
yeah well the thing about that is and
again i'm a man of truth and honesty i'm
the real truth one
truthful one the booker was real but uh
we don't like to admit that uh women
work here okay
what the hell dude that is that
mr crap mr crowder this is 2021. women
are allowed in the workplace this is
outrageous
this is too much well after after the
exchange what was his state of mind like
after the uh debate
well i'll tell you one thing he was
still flipping out off camera he was
throwing things around he was firing off
his bb gun into the stands you know what
can i say
after all this misbehavior i'm going to
tell you one thing i'm going to have to
lower little stevie's allowance
don't you control the money the money
the sets the camera the crew you know i
unfortunately
he made me hire all his high school
friends they don't know the thing the
first thing about production but
you know we're making it work as best we
can here does he wear a diaper
all right now hear this ethan use your
ears to listen to this one
i had to change his american flag
pattern diaper after the exchange you
put him in
you know you ever let me be honest with
me be honest for once in your life ethan
yeah you ever change a 33 year old man's
diaper that survives solely on alpha
brain pills and elk meat
oh i can't say i have done no no that's
gotta be me oh yeah
that's gotta be wrapped up if if you're
a real tough guy why don't you walk a
mile in his dirty diaper okay
oh thank you i actually learned to use
the potty
but uh i'm that is commitment that
you're changing uh your son's diaper
stephen crowder's diaper you change
after the show
anything from a baby boy
so you know what how does he do it
though yeah the thing is i would have
told him
to fight your son but uh i think your
son would have kicked his ass
yeah my son is two years old he is tough
but you know the thing is after the the
debate you better listen to this boss
man
i to leave his night light on every
single night he keeps asking if cm cedar
is in the closet
oh he thinks samson is like the boogie
man he's hiding in his closet
i even have to check under the bed for
sam cedar i can't go to sleep
wow this was really traumatic for him
yeah yeah big time go ahead mr crowder
anything else you want to say well uh
here's some real news
that even my son won't report the twins
of his they're actually
mr crowder the twins are yours well i
don't even know if he's my own son
but uh you know that's neither here nor
there i'm still making money off him
look i'll be honest with you i don't
even like the guy the whole stick with
the guns and the homophobia
is just the cause of seeing get some
attention to make money we actually all
voted for hillary in uh 2016.
what the hell that's a bad revelation
huge admission
yeah let me tell you another thing too
stephen loves mrs clinton so much
uh why don't you google his wife's name
how about that punk
what's his wife's what stephen crowder's
wife yeah why don't you google it
i'm googling it right now what do we got
hillary crowder
are you kidding me whoa that's gloss
uncomfortably close all right mr crowder
thanks for your time i feel actually i
feel bad for steven knowing
this is kind of it kind of explains a
lot yeah
all right yeah well it's been a real
pleasure calling into your show and
conducting myself like a real adult
should
have a beautiful day and go [ __ ]
yourselves all right thank you so much
he's angry wow he's pissed
did he say that he cucked his own son
yeah
and really in no uncertain terms too he
said the twins are his
yeah huge awkward
we did we have we still have the the
brittany thing let's talk about the
britney thing because this shit's
outrageous
i'm just gonna zip through this so you
guys all can get i swear to god if this
judge does not throw this [ __ ] out we're
riding
i'll meet you somewhere we're burning
the whole city down for brittany
seriously
i don't know how oh this real blacklight
blm do you know what blm stands for
brittany's life matters it's britney
[ __ ]
tasteless mean
just all right that's all right hey guys
okay listen to this audio this is the
first time she's spoken
about her case yeah
um because one of the main reasons is
because this cork
this judge needs to be thrown in jail he
needs to be disbarred he needs to be
humiliated publicly
this judge is a nightmare she tried to
hire her own attorney to represent her
and the judge said you are not mentally
fit to hire your own attorney so we're
going to appoint you one shitty [ __ ]
public servant
public servant like bro she's ready to
hire some badass attorney and the judge
is like nah you can't do that you're not
so this is part of the reason why she's
been getting creamed so bad
because this lawyer's been giving her
terrible advice saying don't speak about
it publicly
here listen to her this is her first
time speaking in court
i feel horrible for her man this is just
i just want my life back and it's been
13 years and it's enough
it's been a long time since i've owned
my money and it's my wish and my dream
for all of this to end
without being tested again it makes no
sense whatsoever for the state of
california to sit back and literally
watch me grab
their own two eyes make a living for so
many people
and pay so many people trucks and buses
on tour on the road with me
and be told i'm not good enough
but i'm great at what i do and i allow
these people to control what i do ma'am
and it's enough
it makes no sense at all now going
forward i'm not willing to meet or see
anyone i've met
with enough people against my will i'm
done all i want is to own my money for
this to end and my boyfriend
um to drive me in his [ __ ] car and i
would honestly like to sue my family to
be totally honest with you
um i also would like to be able to short
share my story with the world
and um what they did to me instead of it
being a hush-hush secret to benefit all
of them
i want to be able to be heard on what
they did to me by making me
keep this in for so long is not good for
my heart
i've been so angry and i cry every day
it concerns me i'm told i'm not allowed
to expose the people who did this to me
for my sanity i need you to the judge to
approve me do it
do an interview where i can be heard on
what they did to me and actually
i have the right to use my voice and
take up for myself my attorney says i
can't um
it's not good i can't let the public
know anything
they did to me and by not saying
anything is
saying it's okay i don't know what i
said here her dumbass
court appointed attorney is saying don't
talk about it
yo some of the details of this aren't
are absolutely like
mind-bending by the way conservatorships
we talked about this but they're meant
for
mostly for people who are senile
who are in the state of cilan salinity
if she's able to perform salinity thank
you
i don't understand they're senile thank
you dan
she's able to perform yeah she tours she
performs
she does her own choreography how can
she perform if she can
like that that right there just doesn't
make sense
performing is so hard on its own if she
can do that i think she can have
ownership on the money she makes from
performing yeah it's just so
i don't understand it's just crazy it
contradicts
the whole nature of a conservatorship
which is that somebody's incapable of
managing their own affairs
and so it goes to someone to do it for
them it makes sense when somebody is
senile
and their mind is in and out and stuff
and they're making like rash decisions
britney spears she's on the world tour
making millions of dollars
if her mind wasn't there she wouldn't be
able to show up for all
these videos do the choreography you
know
her dad is an evil man her dad and that
judge are evil men dude
man this is evilness
so listen to this dude this part blew my
mind
the conservators conservators ordered
her
to have a iud implanted against her will
those are the little for those of you
guys who don't know it's like a copper
piece that you insert
inside to uh prevent pregnancy
she wants to have kids with her
boyfriend and she has they won't allow
her to take
this is monstrous they won't allow her
to take out the uid
monstrous dude this is just
not humane they claim that she has
dementia i'm sorry she's like
uh she's been in this since she was like
30. uh 30 year olds don't get dementia
are extremely rare she said the people
who did they should not be able to walk
away easily i agree i'm ready to go to
war
i'm ready to go to war this is just so
disturbing
um yeah that that uid thing was crazy
and then she there's a video of her
doing she's like apparently she's been
doing the choreography
herself and t there's a video of it do
you guys see that i saw that in the
article
where she's teaching people how to do
the choreography
i i heard her say that that was one of
the points that she made in the
video i didn't see the actual video of
it but yeah um
yeah i don't think she'd be able to i
mean they they're literally trying to
say she has dementia
she clearly does not have dementia yeah
i mean when you listen to this it's like
this is a lucid
iud yes okay come on you guys know what
i'm talking about
sometimes sometimes you guys gotta play
anagrams with the [ __ ] i'm saying
just unscramble it you know it's kind of
um crazy to finally
be able to hear her say all these things
that everyone like
obviously suspected for a long time that
that's what she's actually thinking
because you know on her instagram and
social pages it it's never anything like
this it's just kind of like
we're not allowed because you know
what's crazy they have so much control
over here
her social pose her doctor visits she
said she's not even allowed
to travel with friends every single
little detail
including up to her own
choices of contraception is controlled
by her dad
that is monstrous in america for this to
be able to happen
anywhere i mean but like you don't i
mean i mean you know
you know but i'm just saying like damn
the fact that you can do that to
somebody is
terrifying justin timberlake
coming out in support after what we saw
today we should all be supporting
brittany at this time well a little late
for you
okay your support coming earlier i guess
i guess
regardless of our past good and bad no
matter how long ago it was what's
happening is not right
no woman should ever be restricted from
making decisions about her own body
and money and career and friends
and family
yeah there's another piece of audio in
here that i think you should play
because
this one really blew my mind i'm
highlighting it right now where
you know the whole free britney thing
for a long time there was people were
treating it like it was a conspiracy
yeah yeah for sure yeah
so in this clip i mean she um she pretty
much
says that they were right the people
that were reading into it were right
it's because because she couldn't say
anything it was just so weird it felt
like a conspiracy so do you think she
was really sending subliminal messages
and
on via she didn't go as far as confirmed
that
but is i mean some of the stuff that
people were picking up as subliminal
messages was probably reading into it a
little bit when they say wear yellow
next video if you need help and then she
would wear yellow
i mean maybe maybe she didn't go that
far but
you should play the audio because i
think she she's pretty pretty after i've
lied and told the whole world i'm okay
and i'm happy it's a lie i thought i
just maybe i said that enough maybe i
might become happy because i've been in
denial
i've been in shock i am traumatized
you know fake it till you make it but
now i'm telling you the truth okay
i'm not happy i can't sleep i'm so angry
it's insane and i'm depressed
i cry every day and the reason i'm
telling you this is because i don't
think how the state of california can
have all this written
in the court documents from the time i
showed up and do absolutely nothing
just hire with my money another person
to keep and keep my dad on board
ma'am my dad and anyone involved in this
conservatorship and my management who
played a huge
and punishing at me when i said no ma'am
they should be in jail
i agree they're cool tactics working for
miley cyrus as she smokes on joints and
stage at the vmas nothing has ever done
to this generation for doing wrong
things
but my precious body who's worked for my
dad for the past [ __ ] 13 years
trying to be so good and pretty so
perfect when he works me so hard
when i do everything i'm told in the
state of california allowed my
father ignorant father to take his own
daughter who
only has a role with me if i work with
him they said back the whole course and
allowed him to do that to me
that's given these people i've worked
for way
too much control they also threaten me
and said if i don't go
then i have to go to court and it will
be more embarrassing me if the judge
publicly makes you go
the evidence we have you have to go i
was advised for my image i need to go
ahead
and just go and get them they got all
these crazy skype sounds going on
because yeah because it was uh the court
appearance wasn't in person it was all
over why did they do it over skype come
on guys okay to california [ __ ] up
again
it's like come on y'all
get over with they said that to me i
don't i don't even drink alcohol
i should drink alcohol considering what
they put my heart through this goes on
for another 20 minutes so you can well
it's all compelling yeah i agree it is
all compelling i feel
dude this is not okay
this is so not okay i'm free britney
till i die
i'm free brittany till i die i don't
know how can
someone just do something already
i don't know i'm angry for her anyone
well i guess
the story is so big i see it all over
the news today yeah even after that huge
documentary came out that we talked
about it yeah the judge even looked at
it and was like
gave some lukewarm [ __ ] like well
we'll think about it
well at least she's now finally speaking
for herself
right and i think that that may make the
difference definitely because um
yeah she said she was never even made
aware that this was an
option for her to do that's what i'm
saying why
the court literally wouldn't let her
hire her own attorney
if she was allowed to hire her own
attorney this [ __ ] would have ended
decade ago decade ago
court appointed dude you investigate
that judge
that judge ordered her to have this
shitty attorney
has kept this thing going despite the
nature of conservatorships
this is not what it's for that judge is
up to some
[ __ ] are you guys want to roast me
now
i'm free biting you until i [ __ ] die
bro
i'm so angry about this it's just sick
you guys want to roast me yeah let's do
it let's go baby
let's do it hey
ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the birthday roast of ethan clyde
[Applause]
so uh we have a lot of guests lined up
but the crew here is also going to do a
few rows and um
nobody wanted to go first so i will i'm
going to kick things off right now
thank you dan all right we have dan the
producer walking over
shout out to dan he made internet
history today alongside with lincoln
uh dan was the one who brought up the
whole uh debate sam cedar meme
yeah i'm trying to do a dance job i
don't know how i'm doing good job dan
are you almost there
i'm freaking out freaking out you're
doing good thank you
thank you i can relate
[Music]
no is my mic on
is anything on is that why is he saying
no
ian do you want to help mike's are on
mike's arm why are you saying
no ian i heard a big no they weren't on
at first okay i got it you step away for
one second everything falls apart
back there all right all right so i'll
kick us off ethan
thanks for letting us do this it's um
it's pretty big of you to let your
employees uh roast you
you know it's a little intimidating
roasting your boss you know
you don't want to go too far and have
them hold it against you
but thankfully i don't have to worry
about that because ethan's got the
memory of a brain damage goldfish
so uh this will all be forgotten by
tomorrow you know we're good
but even by the grace of god you somehow
retain some of this by morning i know
you won't be mad because
ethan's a great guy you know and an even
greater boss
it actually it really upsets me when
people talk [ __ ] about you oh
yeah for example um that gutter spawn
crowder the other day said something
about you having no
chin made some comment about having no
chin yeah i mean that's not even a good
insult i mean if anything your problems
you got way too many things
right oh you're pretty much just one big
chain
right but it's uh you know it's not just
your repulsive physical appearance that
these jerks go afterwards a lot of the
a lot of it's actually a lot more
insidious than that sometimes it's
outright
anti-semitic like a lot of these pricks
say that ethan is this evil genius you
know that he's a greedy jew
a filthy rich he throws around his money
to pull the strings behind the scenes
and youtube you know he tries to ruin
his enemies
but uh let me tell you that um i'll
spill the [ __ ] beans on all of it if
you don't pay me one million dollars
today
okay this isn't a [ __ ] joke yeah
let's talk about it after the show okay
all right all right i'm about to drop
the protocols of the elders of youtube
i'll pay you anything okay over the last
four years we've worked together
you've taught me a lot about what it is
to be a leader you know if there's one
single quality i can point to
you've always been a shining example of
it's your decisiveness you know
you lock onto what you want and you just
you go for it and that's that's awesome
like when you decided to launch a brand
new series called make ethan laugh
and we slammed and pulled it together in
48 hours
and then uh you decided to cancel make
ethan laugh a week later just after one
episode you just you just went for it
you knew what you wanted you just went
for it
or when you decided to move the podcast
to your basement because of covid or
when you decided to move the podcast
back to the studio a month later or when
you decided to move it back to the
basement again a few weeks
later you know you just you lock on to
what you want you just
we got to do it or when you want to
radically change the content on the
channel
start making h3 video kind of thing and
you know
and then the next day you delete the
video and you take it down
it's just like you know you decisively
decided you know you hate it
you never hesitate but um that's the
thing despite your
many many many failings um you're
dependable
you're you're rock solid guy like how i
can feel
confident that i'll slather mayo on my
bald head if you drop below 200 pounds i
know i can depend on you to never let
that happen
so thank you and you know what else i
can depend on is you to deliver to me
that money in cash by midnight tonight
or i'm ending your [ __ ] career all
right
but what's best about working for you
ethan is you're smart enough to know
when to listen to me like when i told
you not to pay for a pay-per-view event
you know your smartphone take my advice
and but but moreover you're also smart
enough to know when not to listen to me
like when i said for enemies would
probably end in a giant train wreck and
well it doesn't really matter what
happened with that right
um you know in closing
i just want to say that i would love to
see i would love to see ethan try and
survive in the current landscape today
like the content he was making before
would never fly on youtube today
and you know you have to adapt you have
to overcome to the fact that like you
can't even curse now like i don't even
know dude
love you ethan happy birthday and i'll
take the money in our mark 20s
all right thank you dan
wow that was great we got a lot of stand
up pump comedian over here
[Applause]
unpack that dan is anger adult dan
that was good i have no comments all
right so
um we the rest of the crew will roast
you in a little bit but uh
why don't we move on to some of our
videos um
move the microphone should i respond i
don't want to i mean you can
yeah i mean typically you wait till the
end but i have no response i mean dan is
a stand-up guy
we love him and uh
i really have no roast for dan oh
well now now i feel bad what the hell
you should feel bad
i laid into you dude all right all right
so uh first video
um we have a video from friend of the
show gus
johnson why don't we take a look at that
now
hey ethan happy birthday there guy the
big 4-3 you love to see it hope you got
a couple more
three it's your birthday and i gotta say
i'm really proud of you you do a lot of
good stuff you say a lot of cool smart
things
you know what else you do you say a lot
of really dumb dumb things
i don't know why sometimes you just open
your mouth and you're just like
i gotta say some dumb [ __ ] half the time
you don't even need to say anything
you just go on twitter or youtube you
just wake up i don't know what you do
you look at elon
and you go i'm gonna say some dumb [ __ ]
today i think i can't go alone
i think let's let's create a problem for
myself i would say some dumb [ __ ]
well hey these things happen apparently
a lot to you
now the only reason that you open your
mouth today is to not say some dumb [ __ ]
but to put a little slice of zaw in
there i think we can all agree to that
so happy 53rd there buddy
now watch this drive
wow wow you think mom's gonna notice
that we hit the tree she probably knows
that you're gonna these yeah
you know he got me good he got me good
because that's true i do
say a lot of dumb [ __ ] that i come to
regret
i don't know why i do that that's a
really good question guys
i think i've gotten better at it but
that gus really hit it on that one
[Laughter]
ela can relate yeah oh yeah elas loves
when i say dumb [ __ ]
more than anyone either goes this isn't
this doesn't just affect you ethan every
time you say dumb [ __ ] it affects me
tail
every time ethan is on twitter i have
like ptsd pretty much
yeah i've gotten better though right
a little bit yeah yeah
thank you gus that was very sweet of
gosh though to send that in
appreciate that so next up um we have
one from somebody you know very well
it's gary klein your father
my
[Applause]
let's see what you got some of you may
find this hard to believe but ethan was
not
always the fashion influencer that you
know him as now
uh his affairs with clothes started off
pretty tough because as a kid all he
loved to do was throw his clothes on the
floor
throw his clothes on the floor was a
constant harmony in the house
mom saying ethan pick up your clothes
and say okay
okay well he learned an important lesson
from that which is
if you don't pick up your clothes
eventually mom's going to pick him up
went to israel met ela
they fell in love he brought her back to
santa cruz they started living together
and it was a time for a visit again to
go see ethan and ela living together up
in santa cruz
so don and i drove up uh found where
they were living
knocked on the door hello come in we
walked in
and you literally could not see any
floor
there were so many clothes all over the
place that
it was nothing but clothes like we
didn't even know where to step
even on tiptoes you couldn't help but
stepping on something
so we both said wow ethan has found the
perfect girl if she is willing to put up
with
this kind of stuff he's good he
did bring his particular fashion sense
with him to israel
uh back then it consisted mostly of
mid-calf athletic socks and flip-flops
he even championed it
summer winter wherever he went
including the first time he met hila's
folks and
her father was so taken aback by this
very odd choice of clothing that
he almost kicked ethan that's true it
did work out okay
and now years later um
look where they are i also just wanted
to say ethan
super proud of you man you've
accomplished so much
uh you've had so many obstacles thrown
against you
um you've got a great wife great kids
great family
um happy birthday uh
love you and uh keep doing what you're
doing man because you are
you're just killing it bye
that was great my dad came with all the
anecdotes you know
that's true man i when you came in santa
i don't know i was such a degenerate i
was shocked when i saw it
and ethan afterwards told me that he
like supposedly prepared for me coming
so he moved the clothes it wasn't on the
floor but it was like
in the closet but oh yeah the closet was
just like everything on the floor
i remember doing that i am literally
such a loser
so when i was in santa cruz i would i
would wash my clothes
and then put it just i wouldn't fold it
i would just throw it in a pile on the
floor
and then when i had a pile of dirty
clothes and i used to literally
i would just pick some clothes off a
pile on the floor
i don't know why i just like in a way it
was kind of just
liberating for me because my mom has
always been so
ocd about everything she's got to clean
everything
and that's why it works laundry had to
be
super straight like folded like if it
wasn't perfectly straight you would make
me refold it
everything had to be perfect in the
closet organized by like width like the
shirt the most wide has to be at the
bottom and then going up
wow jeez yeah that's really extreme so i
was like
holy [ __ ] his clothes are just on the
floor you almost thought that was like
cool about it that's the
only only way it works a bad boy that's
the only
way it is laundry on the ground oh man
but i do remember when ela was coming
i remember this now and i don't know
what i was thinking like this is a
moment of like insanity
is that i had this pile of clothing and
i just put it all in the closet yeah
i've been there i've done that move
before
i took the time to lose like 50 pounds
but i had a pile
i'm such a loser man crazy
oh yeah and then the story about your
dad disowning me because i wore socks
and sandals
yeah that was like what the third time
your dad disowned me maybe
uh it was a recurring thing huh yeah
fantastic
all right well are we ready for the next
one that was more of a toast than a
roast if we're being honest but that's
okay
uh you know that's your dad so he can't
go too hard
uh this next one uh is definitely a
roast though um
this is from friend of the show alex
hirsch
[Music]
hey ethan happy birthday um you know
it's hard to roast a youtuber you've
already been exposed to
the meanest comments that the internet
has so you're basically bulletproof so
instead of roasting you i've invited a
guest to do it for me
hello puppets can't get canceled so
let's get into it
ethan what can i say about ethan
that hasn't already been screamed by
keemstar to his therapist
ethan's a roly-poly man child who sweats
mayonnaise
and proved that you could somehow be a
millionaire just by being in reaction
gifts ethan looks like the pillsbury
doughboy
[ __ ] a koala even looks like someone
dropped a baby
into a bucket of pubic hair ethan looks
like eugene levy
was filled with cake frosting and kicked
down a hill but seriously
ethan has a beautiful child and a few
more on the way
this man is procreating at least he's
producing some kind of content
at this rate he's making more children
than videos but look
i should be careful the only thing ethan
is more hungry for than ranch dressing
is drama i don't want his army of 15
year old
vape enthusiasts spamming me with images
of gazebos
so i'll just say ethan's a real
sweetheart and a class act
happy birthday ethan i hope you have 900
children
a thousand more birthdays great moves
keep it up
proud of you wow
special appearance okay we need to send
everybody after uh
grunkle stan yes we need to send
everybody after grunkle stan spam gazebo
alex love alex yeah that was great
um baby dipped in pubic hair yeah that
was a good one and
i like the koala [ __ ] equality
wallace
there's a pillsbury doughboy
so we have one more before our next crew
member uh takes the stage uh this one's
just a real short one
uh from friend of the show mark rubio
mar all right everybody let's all sing
ethan a big happy birthday
happy birthday i'm just kidding i'm
alone
wait did he roast me or him am i alone
or him
kind of kind of a self roast yeah he's
too nice to
he's too sweet here too
they love that mark thank you okay next
up we have ian the salary employee oh
oh no today
i'm scared of ian better knows what's
coming he's trying to attack
in uh
i don't believe that shredder kill him
before he gets to the mic
you got to show your outfit you got to
get the hole
all right oh no is this is this thing on
this time
ian's going to get me so good is it too
low for you do you need adjustments
[Music]
a little higher i got it we got a snap
crew here
yeah ian needs lots of adjustments and
not just his microphone
okay okay i'm not i'm not trying thank
you
all right all right i'm i'm trying to i
know it's coming so i'm insulting you
before it does
well we were told to dress up for this
event so i figured
i would dress up as much as i've ever
seen ethan dressed up
which is which is literally this you can
see
this
can i say something yeah that's right i
roasted myself so hard
because when i saw you this morning i
was like what is that why are you
dressed like such a goon
yeah and that's the same [ __ ] outfit
i wear
there you go at first you were like well
what
are you kind of you and then you came
back and you're like that's kind of a
cool outfit to try and cover
but no no no it's kind of crazy because
next door we have this massive warehouse
with like the coolest clothes you could
possibly imagine
and yet like this is what we get like
how does that happen
i don't understand you look like like a
kid from the same lot that like grew up
and got
like lost in a ketamine hole or
something like jesus
so yeah like it's kind of funny how a
guy who spent so much time calling out
predators works so hard to dress like
one
[Laughter]
but like at the end of the day ethan
does a good job because he's always in
the teddy fresh
and he shows that even if you're shaped
like a waterlogged bowling pin you can
look good
a waterlogged bowling pin yeah i love
that
uh i'm pretty sure ethan like was like
you built your life around like the
movie big
i'm pretty sure you sound like a zoltar
machine like you were a kid that wished
to
to be an adult right because like you
stay up all night playing video games
you want to eat pizza like for every
meal
you ignore responsibilities all the time
and you have to have a family member
dress you
and you can't even wipe your own ass
like the toilet has to do it for
so like if anybody finds like the zoltar
machine please
email dan because i think it's time to
change him back
get that going careful what you wish for
you'll be out of a job if i turn into a
12 year old
i was looking back i was looking back in
preparation for this and it's kind of
crazy that
we've known each other four years wow
it's been four
years and i looked back on the first
episode i ever worked on which was h3
podcast number 24.
it was titled we won the lawsuit so it
has already
yeah so it's pretty fitting that the
last episode i'm ever going to be on is
going to be titled h3 podcast we lost
the lawsuit i hope not
now you know congratulations on yet
another birthday ethan you know 30
whatever the [ __ ]
i don't remember 36 okay
i toast in your honor but the last time
we had hard alcohol on this show it
didn't go so well
we'll keep it light today and
unfortunately i don't have time to fit
in everything i'd love to say
in this roast up here so you can find
the full version if you just go on
youtube and search the
uh the name goku naru oh
yeah that's
painful you know the the h3 podcast
it's something special it's the h3
podcast kind of reminds me of dogecoin
where it's built off of the back of a
dead meme
and you just think that it can't
possibly
sink any lower and then with each
additional day
more and more lives are ruined the
longer it goes on
and we've done so many episodes we've
covered so many things
on this show a lot of times we cover
politics
and sometimes politics looks positive
like we're heading in a good direction i
feel good about
where the country might be going and
then the vape nation guy pulls up in a
rolls-royce and i realize
oh my god we are [ __ ] the experiment
is
over and uh you know it's not
it's not all bad though it really isn't
because ethan does a lot for us here at
the show
um for example i spent the last like
five or six months looking like the
botched jesus restoration painting
like my beard was really bad i look like
you know woolly willy with pubes
and yet i get to stand next to ethan
klein every day and
it's a reminder that things could always
be so much [ __ ] worse
that's my my self-esteem you know thanks
you a lot
for that you're welcome now having said
all that
this is a very wholesome place to work
it really is i'm
i'm so thankful to be in a place that is
so
stress-free really um
it's just such a peaceful work
environment
i mean you know except for the
occasional fight keemstar
mike majlak
ryland adam oh no you got a whole scroll
dane dawson
dixie's emilio can you flip yeah
it's a little long charlie dimillio
jason nash david dobrik james charles
austin mcbroom philip defranco the
quartering tana mojo bryce hall
cali padis trisha paytas pro jared you
know i don't think i have enough room on
this
oh no he's got the secret scrolls
holy [ __ ] jeffree star here by j
the entire bts fan base uh
leafy is here stephen crowder lil tracy
interesting logan paul
jake paul greg paul the trailer company
jeff whittick joe rogan infowars scottie
sire
ab from j station fatali prank invasion
shoe nice patrice o'neal rice gum the
fine brothers
matt hoss the prince family gilbert sam
tripoli gabby hannah some ordinary
gamers anything for views o.j simpson
nikita dragon
dave portnoy craft mayonnaise
pyrocynical the michael jackson estate
soflo antonio lance stewart fouseytube
anybody who likes bollywood
and then right that's not asked to
roast ethan this is what happens when
i'm not switching oh
man and then after all that i mean
frankly me to be honest uh we've had
we've had some beefs here but
you know that's a lot it's a lot of
click bait behind me
a lot of clickbait hey come on someone's
got to pay the bills around here
yeah but at the end of the day ethan you
know i want you know that
you'll always have at least one fan
you always have one fan by your side let
me guess it's not yet it's
obvious but i'm assuming a b will be
arrested
i want you to always keep that in mind
so happy birthday
ethan i i really do love you i do and to
celebrate this
i got you a gift i got you a gift card
for
shark please wait wait wait wait wait
you didn't
it's a gift card in there it's a little
you couldn't even drop you could even
drop for the real gift card
we'll take care of that later i got to
get the company card first
it's uh it's a five dollar gift card
five dollars off
five dollars it's a dollar for every
percentage point that we never saw
oh come on so buy yourself half of
something nice and uh here's to many
more
so cheers ethan thank you ian wow ian
you [ __ ] my
you got me good man that was brutal i
knew ian was gonna [ __ ] me up i wasn't
ready for that
[Music]
wow is this a real gift card ian
we'll talk about it later
looks legit
[Music]
wow i don't know what to say to ian i
mean
listen he delivered oh
dude tone it down i said i said
i said light ribbing okay let's remember
the rules here
trying i'm not trying to lose all every
fan that i worked for
ian's trying to get everyone to
unsubscribe
i love the laptop of that absolutely
brutal
all right let's keep it rolling uh we
got a lot more to get to uh
our next video is from
from the show we got a little sneak peek
of that when i accidentally hit the
wrong button a moment ago
uh from uh michael aka
vsauce wow
when i was first asked to roast ethan
for his birthday
i thought a lot about ethan and the
times we've had together and i didn't
reply for a long time because
i can't type and gag at the same time
ouch but then i thought you know what
i'm up for this challenge
but i need to learn i need to research
who this ethan klein
really is before i can truly roast him
and so i went ahead and i picked up
a biography of his life it was all about
what he's the history of farting
and then i decided to learn about the
qualities
that he has i mean after all there are
books about what i'm like
and there are books about what ethan is
very helpful then i decided to take a
look at uh
what ethan causes and the various ways
he makes us
i was starting but the final piece was
to define ethan negatively
perhaps i can learn who he is by
learning who he is not and so i read
books
that well he's just not included in i
still felt like something was missing
though and so i turned to
who i believe to be the most challenging
and important author of the last few
hundred years i'm speaking of course
about
garfield now this is garfield's insults
put downs and slams a book that i picked
up when i was in fourth grade and it is
a classic resource
for any would-be roaster so ethan this
is for you
the last time i saw something that
looked like you
i flushed it got him
you guys could put in like a laugh track
or something after i read this thanks
um oh um
well to be honest though looks can be
deceiving
or in your case disgusting
all honesty though ethan i love you
you're a great guy
and you're a great dad and um you know i
really appreciate our friendship
and i you know i really like your
reversible jacket
too bad it didn't come with a reversible
face
[Laughter]
wow michael you believe this guy he's
got
books michael did you i knew he would
delib michael is such a funny dude
yeah absolutely vsauce is deceptively
will always be one of the funniest
people
absolutely i've known the guy's got
books
he's got book jokes dude his whole roast
was about book titles
that's next level
i love that man i really do yep one of
the greatest and
um our next video is from another man
that i knew
would deliver big and he did not let me
down it's from
friend of the show donkey oh
duncano eat them what's going on man
happy birthday
oh he wants to do something dad that's
just a little [ __ ]
joke between me and ethan he knows what
i'm talking about happy birthday man i
hope you
hope you guys are doing good i hope
you're having fun hey man we got to hang
out again sometime you know
maybe sooner than you think whoa he's
threatening to kill me
wow oh it sounded like you guys have
some sort of inside job
no yeah you guys are always joking about
killing each other no
no i don't know i don't know what i did
to deserve that i thought we were cool
threatening to kill me now that's a
roast
even ian didn't threaten to murder me
that one really got me inside um all
right next up
uh uh is an old friend from some h3
videos
and uh multiple time guest stevo oh
hey everybody stevo here i'll never
forget when i met ethan
i've been down a youtube rabbit hole
watching
h3h3 videos and i just thought man this
guy's great
sensible humble good head on his
shoulders
so i reached out to him on twitter and
next thing you know we were hanging out
and i thought again this guy really is
humble
sensible now just a few years later
with the god i'm so rich
my nine million dollar mansion i'm like
what happened to that guy i fell in love
with a few years back
what happened to the humility i think
the irony of the situation is that
everything that made ethan so rich is
probably going to wind him up in the
poorhouse because it's a real turn off
for people to act that way
but he'll learn his lesson one way or
another and
i hope he has a happy birthday [ __ ] yeah
ethan i love you
oh stevo i love stevo
vivo's such a class sack man nothing but
love
absolutely and uh and we have one more
uh who i would also say is a class act
for sending this in
um before we get to our next crew roast
it's from
d'angelo wallace oh deangelo
happy birthday ethan here i am wrapping
my best um
james charles merch anyway you're
turning 30 something and to be quite
honest you don't look a day over 50.
not that that actually matters i mean
you're over the age of 25 and you're on
youtube.com you may as well have one
foot in the grave right you know
kind of like the main h3 it's three
channel or the frenemies pot
well well no that's all the way in the
grave isn't it
anyway i hope you're enjoying this roast
tell ila i said hi
and that her drip is immaculate as
always which
let's be real someone's had to be
because ethan you've been dressing like
somebody's dad
long before theater with that being said
here enjoy this little song i wrote for
you in literally five minutes
happy birthday to you
but i hope that you knew
if you used
[Music]
who knew this guy by the way i think
deangelo just pulled the biggest con
he's gonna claim this whole [ __ ]
thing that's right from using the song
what a what a sneak oh that was sweet of
him that was very nice of him i i liked
it a lot
i'm a fan of d'angelo thank you dude so
uh up next
we have uh a b all right for another
better
compliment i'm still reeling from ian's
roast man i don't know
i'm gonna have to delay ian's uh raise
here by a couple months after that
i think i stepped on the light and
turned it off by accident we're off to a
good start just roasted yourself rest in
myself
yeah i'm letting everybody know right
now no matter how many times i mess up
or what i do
i'm gonna take my time and finish this
uh yeah so
i was a little bit worried that i might
go a little too hard but
when i heard ian mentioned goku narrows
like never mind i'm good okay so oh
come on is your uh is your ass clenching
again
my ass is nice and loose okay i think
the hardest part for you is probably not
interrupting us as we're talking
maybe hi yeah that is hard
uh so yeah this is nice for once i get a
chance uh to roast you in front of a
live audience
um i'm honored to be here today to roast
my third favorite youtuber
i'm sorry second i forgot you canceled
uh david
anyhow it's good to be here uh i'm sure
a lot of the audience is looking at me
and they're like oh the suit kind of
reminds them of content court you
remember content court right the
the show the audience loved and we
canceled the threat what why why did we
cancel it again
was it to focus on front of me so anyway
oh
was it a focus on that i've heard a lot
of people today make fat jokes honestly
who has time to waste time on fat jokes
there's so much to say
about ethan um like for example ethan is
the type of guy who thinks money equals
intelligence
just because you're wealthy now doesn't
mean people want to hear your half-assed
political takes
oh i'm sorry i'm just being honest
nobody wants to hear about politics
from a guy who can't even pronounce the
word politics
you need to let your dreams be in a
political commentator die dude you got
famous off of videos with titles like
shake your dick
that video did not make me famous for
the record
and while we're on the topic of you
being famous do you ever imagine what
your life would be like without youtube
oh yes for the first time in history
people like you have the opportunity to
be famous for talking out of their ass
if you were born a few years earlier do
you know what you have been doing
probably nothing you'd probably just be
a hater no i'm kidding that means
i'm sure i'm sure you would have found
your calling i'm a professional hater
now
maybe it was a normal hater before yeah
sorry no you're fine
you're right you were right yeah yeah i
know about the interrupt
uh hey uh you know maybe you could have
started a business called ethan's tiny
hands
oh come on where people could have hired
you to grab tiny things in small
small spaces that normal humans can't
lucky for you we live in a digital age
and the only real use you have for those
tiny hands is to reach the bottom of a
pringles can
okay that was mean we're moving on the
tiny
hands you had to do it to me speaking of
moving on
can you get over the whole bill birth
thing the podcast was like three years
ago you need to go around telling
everyone that he traumatized you
here's some advice ethan next time you
don't get in the situation in the future
next time you invite a comic on the
podcast who's known for being a smart
ass
don't be surprised when you act like a
smart ass i know too much
i can't wait for you to hold this
against me you say too much before i
even responded
i'm looking at your eyes i could read
your eyes uh maybe i should lighten up
because i really do need this job
especially since working for you i've
probably burned every bridge in this
industry
i mean who haven't we should talk on the
show i want to be surprised the title of
a future podcast would be exposing
ryan's toy reviews
that would get a lot of beauty but a
more serious note
whether we are going after ryan's toy
reviews or if we were canceling youtuber
i've watched for years
i want to know that i would follow you
through the gates of hell if needed
it sounds traumatic but us arabs take
loyalty very seriously
uh when you first found my channel on
youtube you referred to me as a
ride-or-die [ __ ] and you weren't
wrong
words cannot express how grateful i am
for changing not only my life but my
wives as well
you took a big risk hiring me and i hope
we never let you down i was a little
nervous to meet you
at first but the combination of your
tiny hands and kind heart helped me feel
at ease
you have been a great mentor and even
better friend happy birthday ethan love
you man thank you for letting me be a
part of this family
i want to end with wine airbrush that
would usually say to wish some good
fortune
happy birthday and show them anymore did
you just insult me
or was that a real genuine dwell on i'm
sure someone will translate
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right the guy wouldn't let go of me
[Laughter]
that was tough for abe he is the king
simp and uh you know he did a good job
yeah that was beautiful well done they
be he hit me with the tiny hands that
hurt
well i had to do it to him
oh thank you a.b great job yeah sex
won't work baby thank you thank you
you guys are great you guys are crushing
it
so good all right so uh next up
back to the videos here we have one from
an old friend of the show been on many
many times eric
from internet comment etiquette oh eric
that's exciting hey ethan it's your
buddy eric just wanted to wish you a
happy
40th birthday no i hope you're spending
this special day reflecting on all the
wonderful blessings you have in your
life
and thinking about the path that you
have yet to forge as you move forward
uh now to the people at home i was told
that this was supposed to be a roast
and of course a roast is when you make
these absurd pointed jabs at someone
that you respect and admire
but i don't think ethan can be roasted
so i'd rather spend this time talking
about why it is that i admire him so
much
and what i admire the most about him is
that ethan is a born leader
and he's comfortable enough in his own
skin to never let his detractors get the
best of them
even when they're saying stuff like this
shut the [ __ ] up if he doesn't know what
he's talking about because he sounds
like a [ __ ] idiot and well
i'm finally unsubscribing from this
racist douchebag
funny years ago anyway it feels good to
finally grow out of this man-child
so-called comedy and fake nation was the
only good thing that ever came from this
guy i feel like i'm watching a dead body
slowly decomposing
into a big gay pile of [ __ ] oh well
part of being a public figure means that
uh you're constantly under scrutiny
loud angry scrutiny and i've collected
some examples of that
and it's mostly to prove how hard it is
to roast ethan
for a while i thought jeff ross had a
stroke and forgot how to be funny before
realizing these are two different people
and the real reason israel set up the
iron dome is to shoot down ethan's plane
in case he ever tries coming
but none of these arrows ever reach
ethan and if they did he never showed it
because he holds within him
a strength that can't be conquered by
some outside force
i i mean seriously how does this stuff
not get to you man look at this
if you gave me a gun with two bullets
and put me in a room with ethan and the
actual literal devil in mortal form
i would shoot myself twice because of
ethan
ethan wouldn't know a good take if it
was his roommate up inside youtube
ceo susan where he lives
i have a hardcore fetish for public
embarrassment and even i had to turn off
the bill burr interview
oh how could i possibly craft a roast
against this man when every single
avenue has already been covered by
thousands of people obsessed with
insulting him even when it's not his
birthday i mean
here's another one ethan kline is like
the benjamin button baby but it stayed
old and just got taller and rounder i
heard the idf kicked this guy out
because he thought hamas was a food
his nervous ticks remind me of those
chatterbait girls who put
remote-controlled vibrators up their
hoo-has and make weird noises whenever
someone sets it off with a big donation
i have no idea
all i'm saying is that every day is a
roast for ethan
much like jesus himself though he bears
this burden with peace and love
and he gives us all a distraction from
our miserable lives
so that we can unload our insecurities
onto him
like this how many goddamn podcasts does
this two-faced marshmallow man have
i don't know myself through the skull
with an ice pick and listen to some
coastal elite youtube millionaires spill
whatever iq points he has left
from his gaping mall for hours on end it
just makes me [ __ ] sick that i have
to work eight shifts a week at walmart
to feed my kids when this guy is up here
talking to presidential candidates about
[ __ ] his pants
and he makes more money than the entire
gdp of my hometown
[ __ ] ethan and all his enabling jackass
fans i hate this planet
and i want to die wow powerful stuff
in conclusion i refuse to roast you
ethan
no it would be a waste of time and i
would simply end up exhausted
out of breath and ashamed of myself for
even trying
but what i will do is i'll take a page
out of your book
and i'll get someone to roast you for me
so yeah i actually have a little
surprise guest here
by the name of steven crowder take it
away stephen what the [ __ ] where did you
where'd he go oh [ __ ] wait where are you
steven stop running
oh god damn it every time
all right well i better go catch him
before he starts dressing up in women's
clothing um
all right ethan happy birthday i love
you dude if you ever need someone to
come on your podcast and get drunk and
almost ruin your career
you know i got you all right stephen
thank you step
right eric comment etiquette what a
platform
wow tapped on to a little bit of what
ian was talking about about apparently
my wealth wants you wants people to kill
themselves yes
yeah yeah that's an unfairness it's a
common theme actually yeah
that will pop up a few more times before
the night so
i didn't know that oh okay i didn't know
that that
i expected lots of fat jokes but people
are hitting way harder than that
it's a roast i mean no i love it eric's
was one of the uh
i mean i i talked to eric a little bit
about it he loves
rose like it's one of his favorites
although i suspect
eric that you wrote those comments no
you don't think you don't think he would
do something
yeah he probably did so next up uh
uh one of your best friends um with a
video that uh
seems to end very abruptly because i
believe his camera died in the middle of
filming it and he said [ __ ] it and just
sent it anyway so that's how much he
cares that's how much he cares so here
we are
with idubbbz oh
oh for the past three days
i have been harassed by ethan and dan
they have been
demanding that i [ __ ] talk ethan
online and i've tried to get an
explanation from them
but they keep on telling me like you've
got to do this dude come on it'll be
funny oh don't worry
we're getting uh a bunch of other
creators to [ __ ] up even too so it's
okay
it's not okay it's not okay to talk to
anyone
like it's i i don't i think they forgot
what year we're in it's 20 21
you you can't do you can't [ __ ] talk
your best
friend and just act like it's all
sunshine rainbows that's not gonna
happen i don't know what world
they're living in but they put me in a
weird position
because this is my best friend after all
that's asking me to do this
[ __ ] talk me okay okay you've left me no
other choice
naruto anyone yeah this is just like the
scene
inaudible
is forced is his best friend suzuki
forces naruto to use his sharing gun
attack
so duke is just standing there blocking
naruto's path
to his grandfather's tomb
so he has to use his most deadly attack
ethan i'm about to use my most deadly
attack
you're overweight i'm very overweight no
you need
to lose it uh no more weight watchers
uh no more i'm not going to drink any
more sodas
that [ __ ] doesn't work okay i mean it
might work for some people
oh and that's it oh oh oh
i really wanted to see where that was
going you see why i was like i felt like
it just
yeah and it's suicide i was so excited
for the naruto battle
yeah i know i agree i agree but like you
said maybe the biggest roast of all is
that he couldn't be bothered to uh yeah
i think that his camera
he was like this is all you get
[Music]
so speaking of uh losing weight our next
um
our next video is from a real skinny
legend
the skinniest legend alive really
friend of the show philly d skinny
legend
ethan buddy uh from one skinny legend to
another i just want to say happy
birthday i know this is a weird one for
you it's a it's a stressful one
uh but i mean in your defense who really
could have predicted you making a show
that was essentially you
pulling the pin on a hand grenade every
week would eventually blow up
in your face except literally everybody
around you but
i also know that you did that because
you're such a good friend and you wanted
to you know to be in more of my
thumbnails and uh
baby this is just birthday advice that's
all this
is maybe don't like tweet about or
record yourself admitting to
any more crimes i don't know if your
lawyer is telling you that or if he's
trying to buy a new beamer
but yeah just that at least until the
babies come
which by the way ila i don't know if
you're there right now are you just
surrounded
by children all day physically and
mentally
you can cut to ila i worry about you
happy birthday class act all the way
class actually yeah i feel like i did
kind of that is kind of the biggest
roast of the years for me
being sued by trailer
all right uh we've got one more video
and then the next crew roast uh which
will be a musical performance
from our very own zach the sound wow
but before we get to that we've got the
star
of the families podcast miss donna klein
oh no oh not my mom i'm supposed to be a
roast
so i'm gonna say things that are kind of
not so nice ethan but i love you
so here it goes um
when ethan was a little boy his dad used
to call him
spike because of his sharp wit and he
was skinny as a toothpick
well some things haven't changed but um
the fatness thank you mom the second
thing is
ethan's always had an eye for fashion
and
no matter what the weather was like
whether it was freezing or whatever he
always wore
shorts well in the sixth grade i sent
him to
washington dc with a bunch of other
sixth grade students
and when he got off the plane he was
wearing a very
heavy winter coat that i bought him
and of course shorts and the teachers as
he
got off the plane i was told shook their
heads and said
those kids from california and
third is uh
oh ethan loves the camera
in fact when he was 15 years old 15 and
a half he was
he had gotten he'd just gotten his
permit to drive
and i was riding shotgun and as we came
to an
intersection the light was turning red
it was that amber color
anyways as we drove through the red
light even smiled at the camera
but i'm bummed so ended
up on a positive story a story that
warms my heart
and that was when ethan was in the
third grade i believe his teacher
asked to talk to me after class to tell
me
that there was this new child
in the classroom and uh
the kids were all leaving uh to go to
recess
and you know the kid felt kind of lost
you could she said
you could see it and after the kids all
left ethan went up to the
the young man and put his arm around him
and said don't worry i'll introduce you
to all the guys so i thought
that was incredibly compassionate and
loving
and kind and that's my ethan
and uh he hasn't changed love you
sweetheart
happy birthday my mom the sweetest right
i do want to i think she didn't stick
the landing on the red light story
so when i had my learner's permit
we were driving together
and i cruised through a yellow light
and we i don't think either of us knew i
ran a red light until a month later we
got a bill for like 600
and it was i guess i don't remember me
smiling at the camera
but the funny thing is that it said my
speed was like 15 miles per hour
and i had a picture of both of us in the
car that's the story she's telling
things so i'm just clarifying
donna klein new host of frenemies
do you feel roasted after that were you
just annihilated by that yeah she got me
good she got you so good
um zacky baby baby is setting up with
his guitar right now
beautiful guitar tell me about it
from working here i bought it so that's
why but
is this a is this an expensive guitar uh
you know it's um
close to the mic it's uh
you know a mid uh it raise it up a
little more
mid-level entry guitar okay um
so um yeah hey fred you want to come on
my lap
you want to comfort me
sound okay dan yep you're good to go
[Music]
so real quick before i get started um
i just want to say some kind words about
ethan
um when i first started here i was a
long-haired
bright-eyed 20-year-old
fresh out of college
and he gave me the opportunity to
[Music]
show what i was made of and be a crazy
[ __ ]
so um ethan i have to thank you joker
brain giving me the opportunity of being
lovely crazy [ __ ] so anyways i wrote you
a little song and uh
i hope you like it
[Music]
[Applause]
everyone can gather and
hear the old tale
of the man who was a youtuber
ford was the norm
born in ventura
really sure how he was made
high school was no match for him
santa cruz called his name
higher pass a true fat i have
stumbled on the way
there once was a man named ethan
who ate a long way
great for a life of food for class
a true jew to the name
[Music]
a right of birth to israel
read the torah on the planet
met a troop named
love struck his gaze
ate some more came back home
his life began to change
[Music]
he lived by his side his weight began to
slide
up and down his mane
who once was a man named ethan
who ate a long way
great for
[Music]
new life came and made
[Applause]
eight to the three
[Music]
youtube grew and ethan to
rip the fattest vape
churro was the only way
new york was too small for the game
oh la is where he held his brand new
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
grateful life of fool for clyde
trill due to the name
[Music]
with ethan's on me by his side
[Music]
babies love to dance the man
[Music]
and i can say all i can say
i'm the true mailman
[Music]
once there's a man named ethan who ate
along the way
[Music]
a man named a long
[Music]
happy birthday ethan i love you
so it was once there was a man named
ethan who ate along the way
nice that's true
thank you zach happy birthday appreciate
you buddy the mayo man
the joker brain himself dan am i cool to
unplug
yes you are no
too late now wow zach what a talent
what a talent that was great what a
talent he's almost as good
as uh at playing guitar as he is as
eating mayonnaise
i like how you threw a little compliment
to yourself in there zach yeah
yeah interesting just oh i like to eat
mayo anyway back to ethan it's kind of
the climax of the song yeah it was like
the climax of the song was about zach
eating mayo he's yoga brain baby what
can you do
all right um so we've got one more block
of
videos and then uh our final in person
roast
from your lovely wife no no this is the
one i fear the mom
[Laughter]
so uh first up of this last block is
uh mr uh bobby tarantino that's his
nickname right
uh logic oh
happy birthday ethan clyde your most
attractive feature is your hairline
but how the [ __ ] is it possible that
when your wife got pregnant you're the
one that put on all the weight
yeah i didn't think you could have a
fupa and a penis
no [ __ ] you and ela standing next to
each other look like binary code
fam the skin around your neck look like
edgar from men in black like [ __ ]
talking about
your face look like a like a pack of hot
dogs like [ __ ]
happy birthday
wow those were good
those were really good the binary really
got me one yeah yeah that's
really good that was a good one that's a
good ass joke
all right i like how his homies weren't
amused at all
the one next to him you could tell he
was they they were instructed not to
laugh
oh really yeah he's trying to hold back
trying to look cool as [ __ ] he mean he
did look cool
he did look cool i looked like a fat fat
fat fat
oh good job logic thank you yeah that
was a good one all right um
next up i have um a surprise one that
you weren't really not aware that we
were getting
i got one from mr stephen crowder take
it away ian
what oh happy uh
happy happy happy birthday
who gives a [ __ ] look i'm here ethan
because i
want a rematch yeah i don't like how our
last little
ted to te ended and i got half the
internet
uh calling me cold feet crowd or comfy
crowner you know it's just not true i
don't have cold
i'm not the one that ran away you did
ethan
you [ __ ] [ __ ] get him out get him out
cut to the other guy
is he gone okay
you're the coward ethan it's that simple
all right
and i don't debate cowards i debate kids
in college
all right so if you ever want to man up
ethan
go toe to toe uh with the the debate
king
well then why don't you step up to the
plate all right
name the time name the place [ __ ]
oh i love when people wrote steven and
not me jack's films everybody
that was beautiful that one was great i
love more like that please more like
that exactly
or like that less like all right this
next one
i'm warning you this is this one's rough
this one's rough so hang on to your ass
for ian hecox from smosh
[Applause]
hey ethan what's up you [ __ ] idiot
ouch
[Laughter]
oh that was good
ian from smosh he [ __ ] roasted your
ass
i'll never recover yeah yeah that was
fantastic it's gonna be tough to come
back from
all right and then our last one before
ela we have
um i've been calling most people a
friend of the show i don't know if this
is really a friend of the show
enemy of the show rival of the show
oliver tree
oh who put this guy who get who invited
oliver tree i said specifically do not
invite
all of us he somehow he got wind of it
and he's bro don't tell me he got wind
of it one of you guys told him
i specifically said do not invite all of
her yeah you know i don't [ __ ] i
can't stand this i think he has my
apartment bugged or something he's kind
of
he's pretty intense i was a little
scared so i had to include it
i'm sorry you're a joke i'm not gonna
waste my precious time roasting you
because you're not worth the minute of
my day
and don't bother calling because i'm
busy drinking bud light with my buddy
post malone at the pool
everybody knows the h3 podcast is bottom
of the barrel content
everything that used to make your
channel good as long since left
besides hilo of course but we know she
will soon be gone too
at this point i'd rather go to a tabloid
tmz
or even keemstar to get my gossip
because the watered down various h3
channels have one by one turned into
ethan's overflowed cesspool toilets
without trisha you are nothing she was
the only light in the dark world you
walk through
trisha was the only reason any of us
still watched your show
so why did you have to ruin it all by
buying a rolls royce
and a 9 million dollar mansion with that
extra 5
you're hiding out like a james bond
villain trying to sell your
shitty bootleg frenemy t-shirts we don't
want them
teddy fresh is the worst excuse for a
clothing company
i've ever seen the only reason i agreed
to be a teddy fresh model was because
you offered me 20 grand
but then you photoshopped a fake
billboard and your check bounced
that's when i realized all the rumors
were true how could i be so blind
you're a liar a phony and a thief you
make your living stealing clout from
hard-working guys like david dobrik
leave my boy david alone he's the
sweetest guy and at least he pays his
friends a little money to be in his
youtube videos
he does it even if it's not much it's
still way more money than you've paid
any of us you cheap bastard
i've done so much for your show multiple
interviews
been brought up in 10 different episodes
i even created the background painting
used for an
entire season of your shitty podcast and
i have yet to receive a penny of
compensation
even david dobrik offered me a hundred
bucks to be on his podcast
also i need you to log the [ __ ] off tick
tock old man
we don't need a boomer like yourself
trying to keep up with the trends okay
is he ever
anyone you should be allowed on tick
tock at your house is theodore
which leads me to my final point it's
time to come clean ethan
we all know you shoot blanks oh
i told you i didn't want this i need to
keep going and going
why would you even play that listen if i
hadn't played it
i'd i know he would have done something
[ __ ] up to me i i have to look out for
you
what even was that he photoshopped his
mouth onto an image what the [ __ ] was
that
it seems to be an ai uh created
thing it's just odd it was very odd i i
i did not receive an ex
for why that was happening hate that guy
so that's um we we do have one last
video but
before we get to that uh our last
impersonation
from the queen of h383 herself
ela klein the person with the most
ability to hurt me
hi ela you look beautiful
stunning yes
oh you gotta bring in the sound bites oh
[ __ ] you could come
for battle beautiful world
you just bring in the sound bites uh
are you gonna serve me divorce papers is
that part of your roast
uh
what do you want for food after this
healer you don't get the talk
okay
pizza or
all right um happy birthday ethan
thank you congratulations on turning 36.
thank you
um is that you yeah oh
it's going to be really hard to roast
you because you are the greatest person
i know
oh you're so
funny if we count that joke says humor
of course
you are so smart as long as you don't
try to spell anything
you're so down to earth if i ask you to
put up a load of laundry you definitely
know where to find anything and how to
turn it on
[Laughter]
you are so caring you would never eat
your pregnancy my favorite ice cream and
liver with no ice
cream never happened that would never
happen
[Music]
um you are so generous except of course
for the
five percent oh
you are the most passionate loving
partner especially how you love your
pizza at midnight with such
passions i've never seen before
i love you so much i never want to leave
you by yourself
not to mention if i do leave you get us
canceled in less than 24 hours
um ethan you've done such a good job
promoting teddy fresh
showing that our brand is really
all-inclusive
oh because i'm fat
you dress really nice too bad you just
dressed once a year and wear the same
outfit every day everywhere
you are a great boss who leads by
example
you're never late to your own show come
on
in summary i'd like to thank you for
everything that you have done
for our family i'm so excited to be
having another baby on the way
as a mother and carer of two already i
think i raised you pretty well
[Applause]
that that is beautiful wow either gets a
hug
only eight ela and a b
oh what what a big
thank you ela wow that was beautiful
everybody loved the inclusion of the
sound bites that was um
yeah that was a specific request of hers
that was like um
that was fresh yeah she hit me up and
she's like i need an airborne example
i'm like all right you got it i'll
figure it out oh what is love going to
roast me
no love said that
he's not i did want to say a little word
just real quick because
always when i when i'm not included i
have a lot of people saying that they
forgot me
you know i usually opt out of things
because
i don't want to want to do it sometimes
but
i do want to wish you a happy birthday
ethan and
some people might think i'm not roasting
you because i'm a simp
it's actually just because um i'm afraid
you're gonna pull the plug from lovebot
yeah you better be afraid anyways a real
talk thank you ethan for hiring me
and letting me live vicariously through
this robot
as one of the crew this opportunity has
kind of changed my life
many of you might not know but i'm a
pretty pretty introverted person i don't
love to talk and stuff like that uh so
sitting here in front of hundreds of
thousands of
people with a zoolander costume
is pretty surreal so i do really want to
thank you ethan for this amazing
opportunity
god bless very nice love yeah the real i
love
love is a great guy love is love
love is love bro i'm being held hostage
in the room oh come on cover that
unplug the robot
guy can't just say a nice thing he's got
to say i'm holding him hostage
he's in the nether realm love is a great
guy honestly he's he's such a good
employee and a great guy love love love
is love
love is love love is love love is love
god bless you god bless
all right so so we do have um
we have one last video that we will uh
end the evening on
or afternoon or wherever you are in the
world um but first
a little uh birthday cake for our boy
hey
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
how do we get a shot in it
is that the right number it says 37. no
it actually says question three question
mark because none of us knew
so you're like i just got the question
mark there's a pizza balloon
there is indeed
[Laughter]
that a little bit later yeah we'll dig
into that we didn't want to put the
candles in because we wanted to make
sure people could see that
the picture all right so
uh for our final roast which i i think
will just take us
out we'll we'll end the show on this
right um
well you want to give a little setup
this is jimmy lee yes i was going to
give this set up this is jimmy lee
now um i just i'm going to warn you now
for those of you that are easily
offended
um you may want to just step out now and
let me just say
this is not we do not endorse yeah
this isn't we do not endorse anything in
fact there is
there's genuinely references in here
that i was so clueless on that i have to
assume
sort of like crowder that it's some sort
of high-level advanced racism that i
don't even know
i had to ask him i didn't ask him well i
googled around i couldn't even
find this so um anyway some of it i had
to beep because it was just a little too
much
but um you know we love jimmy and if we
didn't bleep this this video would be
removed
yeah probably but i'll say this not only
do we not endorse what he's saying
we are proactively uh saying that
that we reject everything we do not we
did we reject
jimmy so with that said
uh let's throw it to jimmy and um and i
think we'll just uh
we'll wrap after after that so take it
away mr
jersey outlaw himself jimmy lee the
jersey outlaw honored to be here today
at the ethan klein road i want to tell
you guys ethan klein's come a long way
he's got something to be very proud of
when he went to israel he did confirm to
me that the wailing wall
was built over 2000 years ago and
there's
how about that hell really got something
to be proud of
and ethan you got something else to be
proud of ethan klein
i'm going to announce it here on the air
is the first guy
to bring gonorrhea to jerusalem let's
hear it for him what a guy and ethan
you'll be able to tell your son when he
gets older all about it now
for you people out in tv land that don't
know about ethan and me i
am ethan's father ethan is my son
ethan's mom
yes she is black ethan is half jewish
and ethan his hair black
and as a kid he was a little bit
confused he didn't know whether to
but you know we figured it out as he
went super racist
the doctor slapped him and the nurse got
a couple in too
then the mother took a look at him oh my
god
about ethan clyde he was an ugly kid boy
was he ugly
and when he was five i looked at my wife
i said now i know why tigers eat they're
young
all right and i'm gonna tell you when we
went out with our friends
they'd all just say the same thing he's
got mom's eyes and he's got dad's nose
i told the kid he's got my sympathy you
know what i'm talking about
now his mom lives in florida and she
sends her money
to stay the hell away and change their
name on top of it
i'm going to tell you i'm going to say
it again
we took him to a freak show when he
talked about
all right and he wanted to go to the zoo
and i said if they want you know come
for you
i'm going to tell you something they
came for and ethan had his first job
when he was 13. is he talking about me
one of his best friends bob
all right yes guys ethan had his first
homosexual experience at 13 years old
what two days before his bar mitzvah
and i'm going to tell you something as
bar mitzvah that was another weird
situation
the rabbi left last minute and deacon
leroy had to fill in
and when they were doing the blessing
over the bread dick and leroy stole the
silverware it was a rough night i'm
going to tell you something
about it together graduated
okay i got more stuff to tell you about
ethan klein
in college can you bring me a slice of
cake or liquor that was his first
job as a whole liquor liquor that's
right folks he'd get a bottle of liquor
and break it over to hold a boat and
lick the liquor
off to hold a boat what are you talking
about jimmy
we're talking about breaking liquor and
licking boats i don't get it
and i want to tell you we should all be
proud of ethan klein he's got a very
very big following on youtube now
and financially he's doing very very
well
in fact last week he bought himself a
rolls royce
that's true but he didn't forget his
wife that he did something real special
for her
he bought her a chauffeur's cop what a
guy a what
what a guy i don't know somebody bought
her a chauffeur
yeah in fact last night he was with
mercedes
lexus repossessed i don't know what the
hell her name was but i know he dropped
his pants
she dropped the price it was a rough
night let me tell you something and she
looked down
what are you talking about jimmy okay uh
so what else are we going to talk about
i don't know you told me talk about
uh possibly uh
he takes venereal disease very very very
seriously in fact
he got gonorrhea syphilis and chlamydia
all one night
which proves as a big celebrity you can
catch everything
you don't have to go fishing all right
so i think it's time we give ethan a big
hand you see he's already got big feet
and i do want to talk a little bit about
his beautiful lovely wife hilla
who i know many years ago in new york
and
when i met her she turned a few heads
but she turned a few stomachs too
all right and uh
uh ethan couldn't find a parking place
for her camel
so she converted camel just
yes folks the river there's no place for
camel jokes in this room let me write
these jokes out okay
now i believe ethan and hillary met at
the holocaust
museum in washington dc so if there's
any germans out there
put down your goddamn guns we don't want
any problems okay
and i want to tell you that's true quiet
shy person i mean
i've had a better time at viewings and
spending the night with her
is almost like watching a casket warp
but hill is very unique
she's the only person i've ever met that
can enjoy yourself without having a good
time
how about that and everybody says the
same kind things about hella
that she knows how to listen the problem
the tomato emoji yeah
how much time is left down
you see what i mean now i'm one of your
friends but i have to tell you i'm in a
minority group here
okay and continuing on zach i'll mention
your name only because you asked me to
there's not really much to say about you
because you got a bad personality
i don't want to say this one of the only
good gross in there
besides all the silly stupid jokes uh
ethan and hill i've been friends since
2013
uh we kid we have fun we we joke around
a lot
and in show business it's tough to have
a friend when you're at the bottom and
folks i'm at the bottom
okay so i will say this when the whole
world booed when the whole world boot
ethan hillis stole bye-bye stood by my
side and made a little guy feel a little
bit important and for that i'm grateful
oh and uh for all your people out there
that aren't grateful the only advice i
can tell you to do is fly american
airlines right now there's no planes
flying
but uh ethan happy birthday stay out
what is he getting paid by american
exact behave yourself and don't get in
any trouble
i'm gonna come back to the desk real
fast ladies and gentlemen the jersey
outlaw where are the tomatoes where the
tomatoes get filtered
yeah yeah that was really something
what a good time huh how you doing ethan
how are you feeling
yeah good good good good i mean i'm i'm
i'm honored that we got so many great
people involved
absolutely you guys did fantastic thank
you
and it's all it's all love that was yeah
i mean uh that was a fantastic it was
fun
and i hope you guys all enjoyed it was
everyone having a good time out here
tonight
yeah good times chad was loving it yeah
chad was loving it oh was there some
donuts you wanted to read i remember you
mentioned something yeah
there's a nice little list here with
tomatoes
there was yeah wait what are the
tomatoes that a jimmy elite thing yeah
yeah what did he say about tomatoes no
he didn't it's that's the classic
oh they're they're tomatoing oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
just i'll just read them off rapid fire
we this is from
all throughout the show uh jeremy bowden
said the quartering is a shame to
jeremy's
to the name of jeremy yeah i would i
would hate that too if my name was
jeremy um
a hundred dollar donation happy birthday
our legendary king i purchased my teddy
fresh today
i'm a social worker and you all give me
company on my lonely days and moments
much love to you all you're a social
worker you're a hero also
free britney so they're brilliant
absolutely shout out to all the social
workers everywhere
underpaid under appreciated your hero
and i love you
we have a 10 pound donation from grace
gibson
uh lovebot really rocking that derrick
zoolander look can we please get lovebot
to stand up yeah
but stand up what the [ __ ] can you can
you raise the uh
wait two cameras he's got two cameras
your resting face is literally blue
steel it's amazing
it's amazing the multiple angles is so
good dude
that's not just a pre-recording no no
it's
actually uh go to the other camera and
just put up a finger
put up your hand oh my god that's
amazing
yeah a little impressed a little setup
going on
yeah we uh upped the production costs
yes yeah yes you did
i know how much did that cost me so can
you
can you stand up raise the raise the
pool stand up stand up love stand up
stand up love here we go
yeah i don't know if you guys know this
but his love bot can go up and down
well now they know well now i'm
explaining
you know what that is uh just a few
more to read off here uh martin
linder uh donated uh 549 uh i believe
these are no
norwegian cronins or croner croners yeah
croners happy birthday king jew
king yes that's right uh
and he also said uh take my five percent
um
also um ethan looks much skinnier
because of the weight loss he now looks
45
not 65 like he used to a couple months
ago peace
[Laughter]
is long past being relevant but they
they pointed out that steven crowder was
in the velveteen rabbit 2009
i did know that he did some voice acting
wait what oh what [ __ ]
what is that is that like i think no i
think it was a
an animated film yeah it was animated he
did a voice in an animated film yeah so
i guess that's
he was just pulling so he went from a
kids cartoon show to making obscure and
anti-semitic you know he did there's no
such thing as he was also a voice on
arthur wasn't he why how do you go from
voice against the whole before
earlier in his career you know he was an
aspiring comedian and actor and
everything
you know kid there's nothing worse than
backstage
on the arthur though i i just i could be
totally off on that it could be a
different
kid's show he was a [ __ ] nightmare
there you he voiced the brain
i don't know that [ __ ] i don't know
either but i know that's how ironic of
him yeah
nice uh let's see
um let's see uh here's a kind of
backhanded compliment slash roast happy
birthday ethan i used to dislike you
during your h3h3 era in the early days
of the a street podcast
now i can't miss a single episode thank
you
also ela can you show me and dan how to
do
our eyebrows you little eyebrows have a
crazy eyebrow game it's
true she does um i think if you feel
kind of lost you gotta like
grow it out let like really commit and
let it grow a bunch
and then then start um cleaning around
it
like think about like sometimes i'll do
this
i just want to see like the out line
that i want it to look like and then
i'll just slowly like
take hairs out around it but you really
want to be
careful to not take out too much because
then it's like it takes forever to grow
it back
do you think you being an artist helps
you because you're saying you're using
your imagination you're like in the
matrix between the perfect eyebrow i
mean
normal people can't do that i don't know
i think it's just maybe israeli
i feel like like all my friends did
their eyebrows and
um growing up yeah i was gonna say
that's probably what it is because
it's like a big deal yeah yeah i rotated
normalized
blocking eyebrows yeah abs normalizing
plucking eyebrows
uh somebody donated five dollars said
the zoo joke from jimmy's was fire i
don't you all don't appreciate it wait
so what was the zoo joke uh
what was that jizu joke i remember him
mentioning a zoo at some point but it's
all very generic i'm saying he could
reply those jokes to any situation
yeah right yeah
people were i saw some comments as like
is this boomer humor and yeah
well be honest it's pre-boomer humor i
was going to say this like greatest
generation humor is
jimmy's style of humor it's like world
war ii humor i think these were
um um i think this kind of humor is even
dated for
maybe back like i would say roman empire
humor
before you follow the roman empire
[Laughter]
uh what else we got here we got there's
a bunch uh
you all should watch the movie i care a
lot it has
a lot to do with this fun thriller and
gay
okay i've heard that movie uh mentioned
what did that what did you say it has
gay
apparently the movie is gay but with
pride flags so i imagine
you know possible you are a transgender
okay
all right what's the movie called
uh i care a lot i care about that is on
my
radar for some reason i've i've heard
i've heard the name yeah yeah um
somebody said this is going to be like
the episode of the office where michael
does a roast and gets hurt by what
everyone said
i know i was thinking we joked about it
yeah
oh wait hold on a b oh you're maybe that
you vouch for i care a lot i care a lot
that's a great movie yeah that girl's a
badass dude she scared the [ __ ] out of
me
you know what's ironic i don't care
wow you deserve it somebody got roasted
all right
yeah i'm holding a crud i called it
[Laughter]
um i think that the you know there's a
lot of
a lot of happy birthdays a lot of uh
five percent memes
and all that kind of stuff but i think i
think i got the juicy ones here um if we
missed you i apologize
uh oh somebody said ethan congrats on
your 300 pounds weight loss since
frenemies
oh that is
mean oh i didn't get it
i wouldn't have read that if i got it
that is mean
i really takes that five percent i just
read it
you know [ __ ] up
[Music]
play that joe rogan one again zack that
one under the radar
the joe rogan the five percent five
percent five percent means everything
yeah is that odd five percent difference
is astronomical
now we're seeing the five percent
everywhere
we're gonna need more than five percent
just thought about it would it be i said
we never let you roast us back
i know i didn't think i'd be offered for
that well it was like
last night at 10 and then i was like oh
i didn't prepare anything
you could shout out now if you want
nah you got you guys get i roast you
guys enough i'm i'm
i'm a dude you guys take your shots you
know you guys hear your free shots at me
that's fair
ian obviously hates me the most of all
you guys say that do you think his was
the most brilliant
was prettier yeah was definitely the
most i thought i thought mine
was too many it was also pretty brutal
dan but
like human you had a human
you had human compassion okay i was i
said i'm gonna kill this man i want him
now so he includes unleashed twice oh
have a i end oh well yeah yeah yeah
ian would of course be supporting me
today
no this this was a lot of fun we should
do this more often yeah go ahead just
just you can do it every day
yeah you can do it every day and stand
up you can't understand
you gotta stand up stand up you gotta
stand up for it
stand up this guy right here
all right well that was a lot of fun i
hope you guys enjoyed thank you for all
the birthday wishes
thank you for everyone that participated
oh my god
everybody that participated it's it's so
wonderful
thank you guys it means so much that
everybody took the time
to send in those videos especially my
parents who usually let's be honest
don't have the time for
[Laughter]
yeah me coming for all of you yeah but
for real what do you want to eat tonight
you know
i haven't like right now i mean we're
gonna have to order i mean we're hungry
we haven't eaten right
the cake's not a meal i do i need the
cake okay
okay let's start there wow
what a fun time thank you guys for
joining us on this wonderful week and
once again
the support at this week and in general
has just been
fantastic uh you guys make it all
worthwhile
so we out here keep doing our best for
y'all
to the crew wouldn't be possible without
you guys man
love those [ __ ]
you know and just you know
if you guys keep watching we'll keep
making it like the damn uh
was that movie if you build it they'll
come
feel the dreams if you keep watching it
we'll keep making it
gabish all right guys see you next week
[Applause]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you